okay folks we're almost there we're
going to get started right now um very
first thing we're going to do is welcome
everybody
and uh representative frat you are up
pledge thank you very much
representative uh uh Mr clerk when you
are ready if we could call the role
please
attendance okay uh Vice chairman in
power here representative Guthrie yes
ker is here representative lales here
represent Jella here representative
Kelly representative awood here
representative Melvin here
representative kahill here
representative stavis
representative Tetro here representative
krie here representative Gilman here
representative
Fox here representative
Gallagher representative Hicks I'm here
representative Howland here
representative priest here
representative Frack here and Mr
chairman
present thank you Mr Clerk welcome
everybody uh before we get started just
like to welcome the following three
individuals who are subs today uh
representative Melvin uh who's filling
in for representative Brown we have
representative Fox over here who's
filling in for representative majori we
have representative kery over here who's
TRV okay
now need to explain what's going to
happen with these executing bills
when we scheduled today's hearings uh I
also wanted to get some of our executing
out of the way because we have uh
including today's bills about 26 left a
little under 26 that we have to exec um
within the next couple weeks so what I
wanted to do was to be able to exact
bills in between uh the hearings when we
had time so I made that
um request when we uh sent in the public
hearing and EXA session uh request I was
told well you need a starting time for
the for the exec sessions and I said
that's fine as long as we can still
exact yep that's all fine all right well
a few minutes ago after discussion on a
slightly related subject this the clerk
house clerk who was happened to be over
here
said it says that you're doing them all
at 945 I goes no that's not what we were
doing and he goes well that's what it
says he I said I want to do it in
between bills time permitting as we had
planned he goes well the only way to do
that and this is how it's going to go is
we're going to have probably a series of
rolling um extensions on those bills
each time we exect one unfortunately so
for all of those of you sitting in here
you you may he your bill exact soon it
could be a very long time just so
everybody's aware does anybody on the
committee have questions as to what
we're going to
do I apologize I was told we could do it
this way now I've been told something
else representative yell thank you what
is the motion is the motion going to be
like to continue the executive session
till later in the day or what it will be
is I will any executive session bills
that need to be continued I will say
they will be recessed
until a specific time and that time will
probably change several times throughout
the day okay thanks
yeah further
questions
okay so with that we are going to go
ahead and start our first hearing of the
day and that is going to be on HB
1181 relative to Solid Waste districts
we will open up the public hearing on
that and I believe the prime sponsor
representative
vure
close uh you have the
floor I would also ask um that anybody
speaking make sure you have given me a
pink card we only have one so far um
when you introduce your bill or when you
speak to a bill just we need to hear if
you're are for or against and then
continue thank you go ahead
thank you Mr chairman good morning
everyone uh my name for the record my
name is Dan veu I am uh state
representative for HB for Hillsboro 34
representing the town of Amherst um I'm
also a member of the district Committee
of the solid souan solid the San
Regional Solid Waste District uh which
is a solid waste District formed under
uh eight uh RSA
53b um and I'm here to introduce uh 118
HB 1181 which is an administ tra of
update to uh RSA 53b uh there are three
updates contained in this bill and I'll
go through each one and how we arrived
at it um the issues that we came up with
and I'll try to be quick because I know
you have a busy morning um the first
change has to do with
um how the the land the the transfer
stations within our district handle
Solid Waste right now we can accept
waste from anybody within our district
or outside the district
um but what if we have entities that
have so much trash or material that we
can't accept it at the transfer stations
uh like a school district um the mher
school district has a couple of of
compactors that are too big to fit you
know by the time they they dump out our
transfer station they filled up our
containers so it doesn't make sense for
them to come in so what we wanted to do
was allow them to go to our contracted
incinerator under our contract price
because right now they're paying over
$155 a ton where we pay
90 so uh it doesn't make sense that a
another political subdivision within our
own district has to pay such a different
different rate uh most communities would
service their their schools and you know
charge the the district uh accordingly
um with this update Services may be
contracted through third parties for
public entities and political
subdivisions including school districts
in order for them to go to directly to
the incinerator under the srld contract
there was some question whether we
already had the authority to do that
under this section but this just
clarifies it and and specifically says
yes it's it's possible to do that um
without opening it up to um a lot of a
lot of potential problems um the next
section that we're making an update to
is school boards and
municipalities um
when it comes time to pay the bills uh
are allowed
to
um they're allowed to designate a couple
of members of their Committees of their
boards to sign off on on the invoices
through a manifest process and then
there's a mon there's a um a treasur
report that comes out every meeting and
they uh report all the bills that were
paid during the month with the at the
srld and most waste management districts
we can't do that we don't have that
section under the law um so this just
adds the same language that is governing
uh school districts and
municipalities um it gives the treasurer
the the authority to uh to pay the bills
and by a non-c contemporaneously signed
manifest signed by two or more members
of the of the district committee
empowered by District committee as a
whole to authorize payments part of the
reason for this is that as a governing
body we don't have to meet every month
so if we don't meet we can't pay the
bills which could be a big problem for
some of our vendors some of our bills
are tens of thousands of dollars which
could be a financial hardship if some of
our entities don't get
paid the last
update came up in 2022 as as a result of
covid um one of the we had a bunch of
unanticipated expenses that almost made
us go above our budgeted um
expenditures fortunately we were able to
to cancel a large purchase order which
put us in the black for the year so we
didn't have any problems but it occurred
to us that our only real recourse was to
go back to our member communities and
and ask for more money which they don't
have to they can say no in which case we
would have been in default on several of
our bills and some of our bills can be
pretty big so that could put us in a lot
of financial
trouble um municipalities and school
districts can go back to the Department
of Revenue Administration or to the to
the Department of Education for
permission to SP overspend their budgets
but the the uh waste management
districts cannot so this takes that
language from those um from those
sections of the law and extends it to
waste management districts um of course
we have to ex we have to exhaust all our
administrative options we have to go to
the m the municipalities and ask for
more money and they have at least one of
them has to say no um before we can go
to the Dr and get permission to
overspend our budgets and of course we
have to have the money somewhere we have
to have a reserve somewhere that um we
can we can use um in this section
however uh of course it's the first time
I've looked at it since it was drafted
and find a mistake right away um where
it says in line 26 section one where it
says Board of Selectmen of the member
member communities it should say uh
governing bodies of the member
a uh an amendment drawn up for that if
it's okay with the
committee but other than that I think
those are the three sections that we're
concerned with right now and i' be happy
questions thank you for your testimony
Kella um thank you uh thank you for
taking the question um I'm a little
concerned about um the language on line
four where it says um Services may be
contract ed through third parties for
public entities
um in your description it seemed like uh
you were trying to allow a municipality
to essentially have a
combined um contract with including them
in another essentially govern
uh body a state body third party seems
like you're opening it up to you know
501c3 that that is Contracting and then
anyone can join that 501c3 and they can
contract and so it seems like very vague
about where's third parties who is the
third parties that are allowed to
contract and who like how are they
getting empowered to contract in on
behalf of other
people um right because I'm a third
party can I contract right and so that's
kind of my question and my concern um
can you speak to that yeah uh this is
Services may be contracted through third
parties uh these are services that are
provided to the transport station which
may be material recycling services they
may be Disposal Services uh hauling
Services Transportation where they pick
up the trash and take it someplace else
and this is consistent with the state
policy that we see um State the state
allows 501 c3s and politic subdivisions
within the state to use um State
negotiated contracts so this kind of
extends it at the local level where if
our uh waste district has a contract for
services through a third party that also
those political subdivisions within that
District um are allowed to use that the
the the terms of that contract for their
own purposes uh which would be build
probably through the the Waste
Management District and in that case we
would um
Bill back the The Entity and with any
necessary follow up thank you
um uh so in the example the town has uh
an agreement with these third parties
right it's not the third party agreeing
it's the actual Town agreeing and then
the school district also wants to use
that and you're saying that re urement
shall be made by mutual agreement within
the district that's assuming that that
the agreement has already been in place
um and would such an agreement go
through the
voters um of the you know the
legislative body be able to uh vote so
each um you know the school district and
the the um the town in this example
would each have to agree to such a
contract before that would be um
enforcable or or that you would be able
to um do these Services through kind of
a mutual thing or if someone um because
I'm just saying like you know the if the
town signs the contract and they didn't
have the agreement or someone wants to
back out of the agreement who's going to
be left holding the bill it might be the
person that actually signed on the
dotted dotted line right thank you for
the question um u m Municipal Solid
Waste districts are uh they're their own
political subdivision they're like a
school district they have their own
their own authority uh to contract with
anyone they they see fit um so they like
right now the srld has contracts with
the um the incinerator here in conquer
and if the school came to us and said
you get a better rate than we do can
we use your contract at can we can we
have our material Hall to the
incinerator and conquered and say it's
the you know School District under the
Sal the souan regional uh landfill
District we could say yes but we but we
would have to come up with an agreement
with them uh it's going to cost us $90 a
ton but we have to pay our clerk to bill
you back for that so we would add a $10
a ton administrative fee or a $10 per
time administrative fee so that's all
this is saying we have we already have
the contracts in place they want to take
it Vantage of them so we would allow
accordingly excuse me representa
stavis thank you Mr chair and apologies
for my tardiness to the meeting this
morning and thank you for taking my
question um I'm looking at the whole
whole of RSA
53 which is about
mutually joining municipalities Jo
joining together to provide services it
has nothing nothing to do with
Contracting with private entities uh and
includes all kinds of permissions and
notifications that must be given to the
state before municipalities can join
together in such agreements and and I'm
a little concerned that that this
doesn't refer back to that in some way
so so that it's given the proper
Authority by the state as dictated in
53a yeah the in
53b the uh those waste districts are
given explicit authority to make to to
under to um engage in contracts with
third parties um so that is already well
established U the srld that I belong to
the solid San Regional Landfill district
has been in existence since
1975 and uh
so uh our our primary purpose is to to
have contracts with third parties for
Solid Waste
Services
so I don't I don't know that there's a
section are there any other questions
witness representative
carry so just a clarification on process
it sounds as if the way the process
would work would be you would your Solid
Waste Management District would serve as
the Fiscal Agent for the other Municipal
entity which might want to join with you
on Services right so essentially you'd
have a memorandum of understanding and
you would act as the Fiscal Agent in
this process right we thank you for your
question we would be the uh yeah the the
go between uh they would use our
contracts it would be built to us as the
San Regional Landfill district and then
it would be noted like we we do with our
towns all our every time we go to the
the incinerator you know if it's Hollis
or uh Mont Vernon they go to the
incinerator solid San Regional Landfield
District Mont Vernon and that's where
the bill comes in it gets Bill to the
Sal to the San Regional Landfill
district and in the notes it says mon
Veron so it would instead say you know
if we had a um a sewer district or a
water district that wanted to take
advantage of it in the in the town it
would say you know
srld water district or srld um San
Regional Sagan corporate school board or
you know something like that amorist or
pooll Brook line or whoever was a part
of it and this would be limited to just
other political subdivisions not every
entity in the in the district you
couldn't go in as a you
know a restaurant and say we're with
srld that wouldn't it You' have to be a
political
subdivision further
questions seean I have just you have
another one represent
no uh I have one for you uh
representative uh looking at line
21 um this is an entirely new section
and the title of excuse me the title of
the the section is emergency
expenditures and overe
expenditures when you continue on that
line it says when an unusual circum an
arise could you tell me what the intent
of the word unusual is is
that I'll let you talk to it what do you
mean by unusual yeah I think this this
was taken out of the uh the language
that exists for municipalities um
unusual circumstances has to be
something that you didn't anticipate
because you would have you should have
budget for it if it's something you
should have you should have known about
so it asked me an unusual circumstance
like I said what how we arrived at this
this was during was just after covid in
2022 when things were still kind of
crazy and um the incinerators were the
incinerator wasn't able to handle the
volumes that we we had to bring in and
we had a lot of wait times and we were
getting a lot of charges back from our
hauling service and things were were
running tens of thousands of dollars
over budget so um we realized that if we
went over budget we had no no way of of
doing that
without being in default unless we could
get our communities to agree to pay more
money and if even one of them said no we
we would have been in big
trouble okay I'll give myself a followup
before I go to representative yella um
it
it would it be
better I mean to me overe expenditure
and I I know you said you grabbed this
from other language but where it says uh
overe expenditure is an unusual I mean
if to to me what you're looking for is
really emergency situations I think
unusual and
over maybe a little too
broad um there is a provision if it's an
emergency situation we can go directly
to the Dr without having to fulfill any
of the other criteria um I think unusual
um is like a step back from emergency
it's it's not something that um you
could have anticipated but it's not
something that is exactly an emergency
there there should be a you have time to
go through a process um it's it's not
like it's a you know time there's any
time constraints you you have time to go
through the process that that is laid
y thank you um thank you for taking
another question um regarding these
contracts s um with these incinerators
or or any disposal type of um contract
ha have you reached out um to those
people or how does it um to see if they
would be okay because I assume that
their contract let's say they gave you
at a certain time and they you know said
it was 90 9 $ a ton or whatever and then
now they're Contracting for $120 a ton
and and someone doesn't really like that
and so they're they're like hey um we're
going to try and go with this other
contract that was $90 a ton um kind of
undercutting them trying to raise prices
and saying like hey the the facts on the
ground are X and we need to be able to
recoup some of our actual expenditures
so I'm I'm a little bit concerned that
you may be kind of shooting yourself in
the foot if if if the the company you
know um is put in a situation where they
didn't anticipate you know this massive
volume coming from this one one vendor
that they gave a screaming good deal to
and then it turns out to be the entire
State because they uh because of this
kind of loophole have you talked to them
and their concerns about that and no
that's that's definitely been that was
one of my concerns when drafting this
that I wanted to keep it limited to uh
just small entities within the district
um that could that could take advantage
of those contracts because uh and I
would fully expect that if a school
district had a contract with with a um a
disposal site disposal facility that
required them to use that facility under
that contract that they would honor that
because they would be in breach it's you
know that's you know you you're right
you would get volume discounts and if
you would be undercutting the the uh the
contract in that case and I I would
expect that you know any entity that
entered into a contract like that would
honor it and uh you know I think we
would uh if the incinerator called us
and said hey you're the school's trying
to dump under your contract but they
have a contract with us and they're
required to bring all of their material
to us we we would you know of course
honor that if that's is that that's your
point followup yeah thank you I I was
not trying to to say hey they have a
contract that says bring all your waste
there I was saying I was I was implying
that maybe the contract they're going up
for Renewal and they they're getting
offered now
$120 and they're like wait a minute this
other place still has 90 for another
three years or whatever we're just going
to out we're just not going to sign a
new contract and we'll we'll join in
with this other group that still has 90
for another three years or something
like that that was not in breach of
their actual contract that's what not
trying to apply totally understand I
appreciate your your point um yeah uh
that's kind of the the business of the
srl of the solid waste district is to
have that economy of scale to an extent
and they can contract with us for the
service according to this so we wouldn't
necessarily be undercutting the you know
we're we're just serving our purpose for
that Community they can already bring
their trash to us at that rate but if we
can't necessarily we don't have the
capacity to to handle the volume that
they can bring us they can just bring it
directly to this the uh service that
we've contracted with that's all this
this is is saying so um as far as the
communities go that that's kind of the
purpose of of a solid waste district is
to act as that economy a scale and to
have to be able to negotiate better
contracts um for our our municipalities
and the the political subdivisions
districts okay any further comments
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony I had one pink card on this
bill and I had one individual sign on
the blue signin sheet neither Pro nor
con so with that we will go ahead and
close the hearing on HB
1181 thank
you our next hearing begins at 10: so we
have 5 minutes so I am now going to open
up the executive
session on all our bills that we are
supposed to exact we've only got five
minutes so I'm going to take a one that
I know is going to be very short
and that will be
HB
1180 so we are going to open up the
executive session on
hb180 relative to the
exemption and do I have a motion on
that representative
ales yes yes Mr chairman uh I move that
uh we itl 1180 thank you do we have a
second
yes uh representative kahill seconds
that motion representative Solis would
it yes I think we were looking for an
amendment on
this and uh
as far as I know there is no
amendment that would be correct um I can
give everybody a quick brief here on
exactly the status of this um I ended up
talking with the attorney
who was uh Mary Stewart who was the
attorney who handled the C the Supreme
Court case for the
state um in our discuss lengthy
discussions and emails um
my my point to her was that I think the
road that the sponsor was going down was
actually muddying the waters making it
worse than rather than better and that
if you read the actual Supreme Court
decision it talks several times in there
about ownership that not only do you
have to occupy but you have to show
ownership I said I think what needed to
be done was names need to be on the
deeds in order to claim it she goes the
Supreme Court decision the way it's
written now without any changes actually
does that I said well I think what
really needs to be done is maybe a
clarifying line in the RSA to to so an
individual looking at it says okay I'm
totally unaware of the Supreme Court
decision however I understand that
according if I want to claim this
Homestead exe exemption the husband and
spouse or the the the spouses both have
to be named on the
deed I brought that to the co-spon uh to
the sponsor's attention like I said uh
representative lales said that we were
waiting for um a
potential amendment to take care of that
we haven't seen that uh personally I'm
fine with the current way the RSA is
written I would prefer to see clarifying
language in there so
everybody understand that the name has
to be on the deed to to uh to claim the
homestead exemption so I'm I'm fine at
this point with an itail i I would
suggest that in the maybe somebody uh
next session comes forward with an
amendment for that do I have any
comments representative
Gallagher um yeah one additional thing
I'd note was that um we also had another
bill uh HB 1034 which was uh relative to
uh also relative to a homestead property
tax exemption so um which I believe we
referred to interim study so um if the
prime
sponsor would be um interested uh
perhaps he could uh get involved with
that process to um move his own ideas
about a Homestead Property exemption
forward further questions comments
represent
Davis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for that explanation of the history of
the bill I also spoke with the sponsor
because I had several concerns about
wording uh and one was that it's it's
not a right it's an
exemption uh and it also talks about the
value of the property rather than the
appraised value and I requested that
those changes be made and the sponsors
said that an amendment was forthcoming
and as we see no amendment has come so I
tend to agree with the motion for
itl further comments seeing none we'll
roll
hb180 hb180 itl uh Vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie yes clerk
votes yes representative lales
yes representative Ella
No representative Kelly representative
award yes representative
Melvin yes representative kahill yes
representative Davis yes representative
Tetro yes representative
krie yes representative Gilman yes
representative Fox yes representative
gall
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest
yes representative Frack yes and Mr
chairman yes motion passes 18
to1 thank you without objection that'll
go on the consent calendar seeing no
objections and representative lales I
assume you will write the committee
report yes sir thank you okay with that
we close the executive session on
hb180 and we will now recess the
remainder of the exe executive session
bills HB 1124 1459 1414 1,1 and 1317
a.m. okay with that we will open up the
hearing on HB
1101 establishing a committee to study a
potential State
program and on and
on I see the prime sponsor has taken the
seat representative Reed you have the
floor thank you so much Mr chair and
thank you honorable members of the
committee for once again having me uh
once again for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
that's new market and new Fields um I
have spoken to you all repeatedly in the
past over this year and other years
um about the severity of the housing
crisis um to recap very briefly those
points in the past we are in the midst
of the worst the worst housing crisis
this state has ever seen in history full
stop the worst housing crisis um it is
also the biggest crisis of any crisis in
New
Hampshire it is driving our already
severely aging state
driving the young workers from the state
in droves because they simply cannot
afford to live
here in less than 20 years there will
not be enough young workers in this
state to care for the people in the
state who will require residential care
that is how bad this is that the people
here in this room in 20 years many will
have to have residential care and we
won't have enough people in the state to
literally care for them we have to do
something and so before you today I have
a very humble study committee to study
the feasibility of a potential Loan
program to do two things potentially one
is to loan to load a moderate income
people for a um a home purchase and the
other is to consolidate student loans
and there is a reason that these two
things are
connected so for student loans the the
reason well I'll start with housing with
the with the ability to purchase when we
talk about dealing with the housing
crisis almost all of our proposed
Solutions revolve around rentals but
really home ownership is the gold
standard home ownership is far more
sustainable far better for the economy
far better for pretty much every single
metric you can come up with than rentals
so the goal should be to get as many
people who want to be in their own home
and into their own
home that should be the
gold the reason that student loans have
something to do with that is that
population that wants to buy in New
Hampshire because again New Hampshire is
a very desirable state in every other
way except for housing so it's not that
young people don't want to be here it's
that they can't afford to be here but
the biggest source of that young worker
population debt that prevents them from
so my thought was that if banks can
provide loans for mortgages and can
provide student debt consolidation loans
and can operate at a profit doing that
why in the world can't a state do that
and break even it may require an upfront
investment that then over time would get
covered by the later um payments on
those loans but eventually you could pay
back that initial investment and then
operate in such a way that the operating
costs are
covered and this is not a New Concept if
you've heard of
microloans like um Charities that
operate in third world countries they
allow people to provide loans to people
in those developing countries so that
they can get housing start businesses
what have you and their repayment rates
are through the roof and what it's it's
essentially the pay it Ford method the
pay it Ford Model that instead of that
money going back to a profit like it
does with a private bank that you can
simply take that money cover your costs
and invest in the next wave of people
who need homes or need their student
loans consolidated it's also the the
same pay it for method or model that
Habitat for Humanity uses the idea that
there's an in initial investment where
you get people to pay into what they're
going to get and then that those
I think that in the midst of this
terrible crisis and this is something
that's been true historically whenever a
country or a state is experiencing a
very bad situation usually they have to
start thinking outside the box for
Solutions and oftentimes they end up on
the Forefront of um that particular
solution right they come up with
something new and Innovative that works
and I think New Hampshire has a chance
if we study this and we think about it
maybe there's a chance we can make this
work in a zero eventual cost to the
state way where we could reach extremely
high levels of home ownership in this
state extremely low student debt um
burden in this state and that we could
be a leader in the entire country for
how we do things and really show the way
forward so I think considering the
severity of the
crisis that a a lowly study committee at
the very least is warranted I don't have
all the answers but that's why we have a
study committee with that I'd like to
take questions but I really encourage
the committee to just um consider having
solution
representative
priest thank you Mr
chairman
uh and thank you for taking my question
uh my first question is have you taken
into account first we know that there's
a housing crisis going on and but have
you taken into account all the housing
units that are now currently been
approved and are under construction and
will be occupied within the next uh 3 to
five years
so thank you for the question and so
that question doesn't go to the um kind
of merits of the underlying idea but how
much of a crisis do you project there
will be in the future kind of question
and the answer is um essentially yes so
even the units that are being built most
of them are rentals that's not ideal
that's kind of a a Band-Aid on a bullet
wound in a lot of cases secondly there's
really not a lot not making those
rentals affordable we're still we want
to believe that the Market's always
going to like if you just build enough
it's going to drive down those prices
but we've seen over and over and over
again how that has not been the case and
that without some way to make developers
offer lower income units that they're
just going to build to the highest uh
paying customer so it it has not proven
to solve the crisis yet um and for those
two reasons it's not affordable it
hasn't has been affordable in this state
to Young workers and also it's not the
same thing as owning a home for those
two reasons you are actually correct
when you said it was off topic um and
now we're hearing very off-topic
comments for the members of the
committee please ask questions that are
directed to establishing a committee for
these purpose that way we'll be uh do
you have a quick followup repres follow
as a clarification I because we keep
hearing this house in crisis housing
crisis and I know from the city of
Manchester has done a lot and I you know
I'm pretty sure that most of them are
rental but I just wanted to have that
out there the my next question is why
are you combining the student
consolidation loans into this because
there are two important issues and they
should be dealt separately thank you
thank you for the question I thought I
answered that in my testimony but I
guess I wasn't clear enough and I do
want to go out there I am the last
person in the world that should um ever
criticize anyone for being emotional
about one of these issues um but I do
feel like there's some emotion here that
I don't understand where it's coming
from but to answer the question um I I
as I said well I just wait for him to
hear the answer as I said in my
testimony as the situation currently
stands young working people who want to
buy a home often times that young
working population their highest debt
burden comes from student loans and that
is a huge barrier for them to purchase a
home and that is why considering both
student loan consolidations which banks
Do privately at a profit and mortgage
loans which banks Do privately at a
profit are appropriate because if you
can imagine a state this state which is
beautiful and wonderful in every way
except for its housing affordability now
having near perfect home ownership rates
everyone who wants to own a home can and
Incredibly low student debt burden
that's a state that everyone should want
to live in very good representative uh
do you still have a question
representative Guthrie uh my question is
asked I I felt there was some uh I
couldn't understand why you put the
student loans in with the housing but uh
it has I apologize further questions
representative Gallagher um so
I'm glad to hear you mention Habitat for
Humanity in your testimony for
disclosure sake uh my brother works with
them out in Portland Oregon um so my
question is um
under uh Roman 3 starting at line 13 it
has the list of um entities that
there'll be or
organizations that um they'll be seeking
testimony from if this is based on the
Habitat for Humanity loan model then why
not include them as one of the um
entities to seek information from thank
you so I I didn't to be very very clear
I didn't say it's based on the Habitat
for Humanity model I said it's based on
the pay it Ford model which Habitat for
Humanity and or other organizations like
microloans also use so it's kind of
Divergent um but which means the same
but taking different paths um the the
I'm glad brought this up because I meant
to bring it in my testimony the list of
entities that will be solicited is not
exclusive so anybody can come and
testify in these study committee
hearings um but I did put together this
list on the basis of um input that I
solicited from New Hampshire housing so
New Hampshire Housing Authority or
Finance Authority was very um
instructive in including at a bare
minimum the organizations that should be
solicited for input in the study
committee question representative status
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question do you have a working
definition of low to moderate income
households there are working definitions
um this is LMI is a well understood uh
uh term it depends on which governmental
entity what exact definition that they
use but that would also be part of what
the study committee would determine they
could determine it's also regionally
based for most of those federal agencies
they they determine what LMI means in a
particular region so that might mean
that the study committee decides that a
uh a qualification may be different in
Coos than it is in Rockingham but again
that's what would be up to the study
committee to determine which of those
federal agencies um definitions to
follow representative
lales yes thank you for taking my
question
um the housing crisis in New Hampshire
has existed for a while it's my
understanding that we have a a committee
established uh a comprehensive committee
bipartisan that's looking into the
housing crisis why do we need another
committee to
study
housing um thank you representative and
may I just say it's a pleasure being
able to see you when you're asking me a
question instead of looking across as
speaker um I think you might be
referencing the special committee on
housing which I'm a proud member of um a
legislative committee is different from
a study committee so we do study
committees on many things because
legislative committees can only hear
bills they so we are taking an
information on bills that have been come
up with and put before us we can't study
committee or legislative committees
can't really write their own bills
individuals can individuals from those
committees can but the committee itself
just hears bills a study committee and
there are many study committees studies
an issue to come up with proposed
legislation so again this would be
studying the feasibility and hopefully
the committee would put to decide that
something is feasible and put together
that something in a proposed legislation
which then would come to the housing
committee um for its hearing so two
different roles thank you thank you rep
representative priest thank you Mr uh uh
chairman for allowing me to ask another
question of course you uh you're
familiar with the Southern New
Hampshire uh work um Southern New
Hampshire um SE Coast Workforce housing
what's that Sea Coast Workforce housing
no no no no um Housing Works that's been
in existence for years now and it serves
the areas between Manchester and Nashua
and they are doing this this exact thing
is providing loans for low and moderate
income
households have you consulted with
them uh no but I would I would suggest
that they are not covering everyone who
needs to be covered every low to
moderate income family that wants to
purchase a home because we still have
the housing crisis anything that's
existed for years as you have just said
is not producing results because we're
in the situation we're in and um as
Aeros Smith once said if you always do
what you've always done you'll always
get what you always got if we're here in
a housing crisis then obviously the
things that we've been doing all the
different independent um charity works
it seeing no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you Mr chair I
uh did you fill out a pink card by the
way thank you for reminding me um I also
do not have any other pink cards I have
the blue sign in sheet Ben Frost signed
in in favor he's from New Hampshire
housing with that we will go ahead and
right
okay now we're going to reopen uh the
recessed executive session
on uh several bills we're going to start
right at the top with this one we have
about 25 minutes before our next hearing
so I think we should be able to maybe
get one maybe two out uh but we're going
to open up an executive session on HB
11124 relative to limiting the conflicts
of interest and excess concentration of
power Municipal boards and committee
members and with that I am going
to recognize representative power who
amendment thank you Mr chairman I would
like to offer the committee um amendment
to House Bill
1124 and that would be Amendment
d09
79h uh thank you do we have a second on
that I'll second a motion representative
lales seconds the motion representative
power would you like to speak to your
Amendment um thank you Mr chairman so
um to this particular Bill there was a a
series of amendments and changes to the
bill based on um feedback after the
hearing
so with regards
to the latest Amendment which is
0979 h i I'll go over what the changes
are so first
um Town manager or other administrator
is removed from the list of roles in
subsection 1A and instead addresses that
the that role distinctly in a new
subsection and it's moved down to uh
Section 1
D um so as to retain the same
restrictions as in 1A accept the
appointed role of tax collector as
authorized by RSA 37 col
16 um and that avoids a a conflict and
then um all the subsequent subsections
are then re renumbered so additionally
added to subsection section 1e um a
phrase preventing a selectman from
serving on an elected Board of assessors
that that is um added um to the bill
language and a new section two is added
um see with regards to applicabil
applicability allowing for a
transitional implementation by allowing
any member holding conflicting positions
to remain in those positions until the
next election thereby allowing anyone in
um such a situation to either to choose
to not run again if the term is ending
or to resign thereby creating a vacancy
that would need to be filled for the
balance of the term and then finally and
in section three which was previously
section two it just changes the
effective date to upon
passage thank you representative power
for the explanation do we have any
comments or questions representative
Gallagher um so yeah just kind of a
question for
clarification so this since this one um
0979 H and we've is and we've got um two
separate amendments here I'm assuming
that we're doing this one instead of the
other one and therefore won't be
considering that the other
representative
lales thank you Mr chairman um I had a
chance to speak with the prime sponsor
this morning on on this I feel that this
uh is very much needed uh I talked with
him
specifically about one possible addition
is when you have a
a in most cases there you can't be a
selectman and hold a full-time position
which makes sense because then you're
you're bossing yourself but in the case
where you have a
part-time
position but as a department
head then I don't feel that that person
should also be a selectman I spoke with
the with Prime sponsor and uh down the
road uh with the uh uh other body uh we
hope to make that uh addition but I
think this is very much needed that's an
excellent point I was going to make that
point that if there are other potential
inclusions like you suggest once it goes
to the other other side of the wall then
that'd be a great place for it
representative uh have representative
Elward first yes I just have a question
about one uh K lowercase
k it says no full-time Municipal
Employee or department head Shall Serve
on any budget or Finance board or
Committee of the same
municipality does or committee mean any
committee
I will let representative power read
you based on my reading of of of that um
section K it would be um a
committee because it says budget or
Finance board would be one noun or
committee would be a second
entity follow up Mr chairman go ahead
Guthrie thank you uh Mr Speaker I guess
probably I'm the odd man out because my
first question was why do we need this
and uh maybe it's a difference of of
towns and where you're living but uh I I
don't see any
reason given as yet to me why we would
have such a comprehensive Bill covering
what the town officials can do uh I
wouldn't raise the question as to uh the
selectman not being on the board of
assessors I thought they were the
assessors they are in my town uh we have
a we
uh have that work uh farmed out but we
are still the
assesses and I think that's I don't know
the chapter and verse but I think the
selectman being assesses is a a matter
of Law and uh I I feel very
uncomfortable uh when you tell me that I
can't serve on the board of selectman
and the school
committee I think they
uh in some towns that's a good thing I
don't see any conflict there uh I think
that uh uh there should be a real close
relationship particularly when the
School departments spending all the
money uh and you ought to have as uh as
close an association as you can and
that's to have at least uh one member on
the school committee so Mr chairman I I
I don't see any reason for this bill uh
and I haven't heard any answers as to
particularly whether or not the board of
assessors uh cannot be the selectman
thank you representative power thank you
Mr chairman I I'm able to answer that um
inquiry by represent the representative
so
um in some
municipalities um the the assessors are
elected and that's referred to as the
board of assessors in municipalities
where that those positions are not
elected you are correct in fact correct
the Selectmen function in that role as
the assessors so what this um Amendment
seeks to do is to
um
prevent an individual from being elected
to both the select board as well as the
board of accessors at the same
time follow up Mr chairman just quickly
on the on the answer sorry I'll get
right back to
though thank you Mr chairman I like I
like this bill I think that it um goes a
long way to prevent concentrations of
power especially in small towns if
there's a
concern that there won't be enough
people to fill these roles I don't think
that is a valid concern I think that
this might actually help with that uh
we've heard that concern before because
I think more people more likely to be
come involved if some people aren't
running everything in the
towns represent
Guth thank you and thank you for your uh
answer uh regarding the board of
assessors but is it clear that the board
of
assessors in in this case is
elected and the the fact is the Bo of
represent P thank you Mr chairman um I'm
happy to respond to that so I am
confident that the language is is sound
um the prime sponsor as as well as
myself I I pointed that out for
consideration for because that
distinction might not have been um
realized by the prime sponsor when the
bill was drafted and furthermore this
language was um vetted and analyzed by
the new Hamp the attorney from the New
Hampshire Municipal Association as well
as OS so I am confident that that that's
appropriate and proper language again
thank you madam repres
representative thank you Mr chair um I
also like this bill and intend to vote
in support of it uh I started out be
being very much opposed to it uh on a
theoretical level but it's actually
happening in my municipal it now and
it's not a very good feeling uh and so
in in hindsight and upon further reading
and and I'm grateful to have the amend
Amendment which improves the bill um I
do support this Bill thank you repres
represent kahill thank you Mr chair um
yes I'd like to Echo my colleagues um
this amendment goes a long way to
strengthening this bill this is um one
of the better amendments I've seen out
of our committee and this is a good bill
and I will be supporting it
rep representative
howand so I actually served six years on
the school board and the Town Council at
the same time um I I would not recommend
doing it by the way it's a lot of work
um um but I think the distinction that I
had was that I in the school board I was
in a Cooperative district and so uh
there was a um a uh the voters of of the
entire Cooperative were voting on the
budget I didn't have the power like I
did and the on the Town Council where I
was approving the budget they were
separated and so in that case there was
a safeguard that allowed it that said um
I I don't think it's really I mean there
was some benefit that when I was on the
school board and the Town Council that
we did a bunch of Cooperative things
together uh there was a large summer
program that served our students uh
there was when we built the Middle
School changing roads and things we work
together to try to save uh save money
but overall I I just don't think it's a
really good idea I think you need
different voices on those two separate
uh
setups further comments representa P
thank you Mr chairman I'll take this
opportunity to speak to the underlying
Bill seeing that the amendment is the
bill so this bill is a common sense bill
that limits conflicts of interests in
positions of local government duties and
responsib posibilities of certain
Municipal municipal offices are such
that when an individual holds two of
these offices or they might be an office
holder and also be an employee of the
municipality at the same time there can
be actual conflicts of interest or the
appearance of of such so this bill is
straightforward um the amendment is is
is a an improvement over the bill as
introduced the Bill's logical and
importantly it provides checks and
balances in order to protect the people
who are governed by these office
holders for the
comments representative car I do have a
question regarding k um and the
committee issue so with a technical
Review Committee that's usually made up
of department heads how would this
conflict
could you could you ask that again
please just make sure everybody heard it
so okay line 31 um or 32 actually it
talks about committees just generally
speaking committees
non-specific technical review committees
which advise planning boards uh at the
municipal level are usually made up of
department heads so how would this
Committee we have somebody who believes
he can answer represent kahill I had
this same question because multiple
department heads in my town sit on our
TRC committee but if you if we read this
s read and I had to read this a ton of
times here no full-time Municipal
Employee or department head Shall Serve
on any Budget Finance board or Committee
in the it is talking about budget and
finance this sentence is if you just
circle those two two words it's not
talking about a TRC committee it's
specifically talking about budget my
ores I I will agree that maybe that last
line could have been drafted slightly
better but it is what it is for now um
further comments or questions I'll just
kind of reiterate what uh representative
power said um I think on policy-wise
this is really an excellent Bill she
mentioned that rep uh n Grace from
New Hampshire
Municipal um worked very closely with
representative spills spillsbury to get
this thing uh the bill the what's in
front of you finalized I believe it's a
really good work it is it does provide
checks of balances
and also along the lines of the
separation of power so I'm fully in
support further comments
questions seeing none we'll ask the
clerk to call the role
on Amendment
79h thank you Mr
chairman Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
no clerk votes yes representative asilas
yes representative Yella
yes representative Kelly
yes representative awood yes
representative Melvin yes representative
Cahill yes representative stavis
yes representative
Tetro yes representative Kerry yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Fox yes representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative howand yes representative
priest yes representative Frank yes and
Mr chairman
yes motion passes 19
to1 thank you Mr clerk uh without
objections this will go on the
cons oh thank you very good uh now I am
looking for a motion of on 11:2 four of
uh OTP as amended representative power
thank you Mr chairman I move House Bill
1124 ought to pass as
amended and representative McDonald
seconds that uh since the amendment was
the underlying Bill what we're voting on
now I assume there's no more
discussion seeing none when the clerk's
amended
okay uh otpa 2024
H Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guth I am
overwhelmed
yes
uh cler votes yes representative Silas
yes representative Keller yes
representative Kelly
yes representative award yes
representative Melvin yes representative
kill yes representative stavis yes
representative
Tetro yes representative Kerry yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Fox yes representative
Gallagher yes representative
Hicks yes representative Howland
yes representative priest yes
representative Frank yes and Mr chairman
yes motion passes 20 to Zer okay thank
you now I assume this will go on consent
without any objections I see no
objections and representative power will
be the committee report
author on HB
11124 and with that we will close the
hearing on HB
11124 okay I think we can knock out one
more really quick um on the executive
session going to open up executive
session on HB
1459 relative to policies that M
municipalities are preempted
from
uh where was
acting okay um on that uh representative
Cahill I understand you have a
motion yes I have a motion of
itl is that do we have a second on that
I second that representative Elward
seconds that representative K would they
like to speak yes just briefly um uh the
prime sponsor has since resigned and um
um then we will not be moving
forward thank you representative I'll
also note that we had to introduce the
bill because he was no longer here and
there was nobody else here to do it for
him so uh in general when that happens
in this committee it is an itl is there
any further comment on
that seeing none when the clerk is ready
we'll call a roll on itl motion on
1459 okay uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie collect votes yes
representative
Lis yes representative
Ella yes representative Kelly yes
representative aood yes representative
Melvin yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes representative
Tetro yes representative Kerry yes
representative yman yes representative
Fox yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
representative fra yes and Mr chairman
yes motion passes 20 to zero okay thank
you Mr Clark 20 to Zer we'll go on
consent without objections seeing no
objections consent calendar it'll be
representative kahill will write the
committee report and with that the
executive session on HB
1459 is now closed our next public
hearing sessions in four minutes so with
that we will recess the remainder of the
executive session bills which we have
two remaining uh we will just throw a
time on that of let's say U 11:00 just
to be safe and with that we we will
recess those
two and in 4 minutes we will open up the
next uh house session while we have
everybody here um or almost everybody
here issue on our the rest of our
executive sessions um hopefully did you
get okay um we are going to have after
today roughly a little under 20 bills
left to
exact the problem that we're running
into to explain this to uh
representative stavis majori and power
this morning I've been going over it for
the last week and I trying to find a
solution originally we had talked last
time we met of either next Monday or
next Friday holding an exec session um
the problem with Friday is if we do them
on Friday the committee reports aren't
in and then all those 20 bills are going
to end up on the very
final house session and it's just going
to be too many there's going to be some
that we're going to be debating and and
it's going to be
excessive so the options that I threw
out and uh we you can talk amongst
yourselves representative stavis and and
I will talk to our side and she can talk
to your side but we're going to have to
do something next Monday unfortunately
okay so the the question then becomes
and and the other reason I want to get
this done next week is any exact bills
that might
need to be extended for amendments or
whatever that gives us the 20th which is
a Wednesday in the morning to get those
done and the committee reports done
immediately then into the calendar
because that's our last day that's it so
unfortunately we're going to have to do
something next Monday
um I mentioned to representative the the
representatives I mentioned before that
we can either uh do a halfday morning
half day afternoon and get done as much
as we can or we can just do just list
them all and and go for it I that's my
preference but we will talk amongst
ourselves talk with you all and then
figure out what we're going to do but we
are going to have to do something next
Monday okay uh one minute and we'll
hearing
okay
folks came
through
okay all right we're going to open up
the uh hearing now at 10:45 we have HP
1460 relative to the
sale of County property and I see the
prime Spa
representative burough is here
representative burough did you fill out
a pink card yet um I did not you grabbed
one when you're done thank you okay
thank you okay very good uh
representative burrow you have the floor
okay thank you Mr chair and thanks
members of the committee I'm Anita
burrow I represent Carol to and I'm here
to talk about hb1 1460 which is a bill
which spells out the process by which a
county must F must follow in either
selling or Leasing county-owned Property
um I want to talk about the impetus for
this bill which involved a historic
building in Carol County it was our
historic Courthouse it's a beautiful
building um it had an assessed tax value
of approximately
$22,000 it is almost $1,000 Square ft
and it sits on 2.6 acres in oopy um our
County Commissioners decided to sell the
building due to the cost of Maintenance
and to put it up for sale um the
director of our maintenance Carol County
maintenance stated that the building was
in impressively good shape and two
nonprofit organizations expressed
interest in the property one was a
charter school another was an affordable
housing
organization um the charter the
affordable housing organization said if
the charter school wants to purchase it
we're going to back out so the charter
school ought ultimately bought the
$1 now there were voters in our County
who felt that they would have liked more
notice about the impending sale there
was there was an article in the paper um
it it was notice but people felt they
wanted an opportunity to provide public
feedback about the sale of the property
and they thought that there should have
been more public discussion regarding
the use of a building the building for a
sober living facility affordable housing
or other non for-profit activities and
most importantly the citizens many I
shouldn't say the citizens many citizens
in Carol County felt that an asset of
theirs was sold that squandered their
taxpayer dollars by selling it for a
dollar rather than closer to what it was
worth
um now the current SC in this bill the
current statute was amended to state
that the County Commissioners can make a
sale or lease of County property with a
competitive B bidding process followed
by a two-thirds vote of the delegation
and by the executive committee the
property can be listed with a realtor
but not required and or the property May
be transferred to a development uh
Authority uh 15 days notice to the
public would be required and the public
must be given an opportunity to actively
participate in the bidding for such
property I'm not going to go through all
the details but I think one of the Crux
of the bills is a requirement for an
qualified appraiser to conduct an
appraisal of a bill of the building and
what are the reasons for that one I
think it's really important that the
taxpayers and citizens know what the
fair market value is of a of a property
that belongs to them it's a county
building and that the public isn't
underselling the land um or the building
that could deprive the taxpayers of
funds um I think it's a way to provide
transparency and greater public trust um
by using a qualified third party I think
that helps do that and so the community
can be sure that the sale was conducted
fair and above board um a professional
valuation also helps um with the
negotiations so we know what we're
dealing with if it's a clear we have a
clear idea what the fair price is and
the county can avoid being pressured
into a low ball Offa offer and it can
uncover potential issues like asbesto
structural concerns or environmental
hazards that will also um be helpful in
the um in the selling process and
finally it supports the best use
determination for the building so um
I'll end there um I will end there with
that and see if if people have questions
thank you for your testimony uh
representative
Elward yes thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question on um line
10 Roman
1 it gives a adequate notice of a
minimum of 15 days to the public of such
a
sale and the public shall be given the
opport opportunity to actively
participate in the bidding of such
property do you believe that 15 days is
adequate
notice I personally would like it to see
see it be 30 days um I I I think the you
know I I think that buying a bill a
property of this size is a big deal for
a nonprofit they need to know what
they're getting into so yeah I would
prefer to see 30 days to be honest with
you thank you representative Yella
hi thank you um in the example uh that
you just gave
um it seems
like you may have glossed over a point
that is currently in statute that the
that the County Convention had to vote
to ratify that sale of it for $1 so
are so if there was concerns by those
those County Convention members they
could have had the power to make that
cell null and void um so how did that
vote go was that a close vote and that's
why we're trying to move it from
majority to 2/3 or or was it just
overwhelmingly we're just going to pass
this I actually don't remember the final
vote I mean we are you know I in in
County to be honest we usually split on
party lines so my guess is that it was
something like 105 I and I have to go
back and check the vote and I'm going to
say something very honestly here I think
that um several of us were as sleep at
the switch when the sale went through
and that's on us that was on us not on
on um anybody else okay thank
you represent
priest thank you Mr uh uh chairman and
thank you for taking my question uh
during this time isn't a a policy that
when the County Convention is a
considering a motion like this to have a
public hearing be held at that time so
and I would not call it a public hearing
the way that um we operate in Carol
County is that before a meet before a
meeting people can make public comment
um but they cannot ask
questions
okay
representative
Gallagher um so one of the groups you
mentioned in describing your uh
motivating example was an affordable
housing group I'm wondering what sort of
impact you foresee this legislation
having on our current housing
crisis I I don't think I can answer that
I mean it that would depend I mean in
this particular scenario you know was
this building appropriate for affordable
housing I can't answer that without
having the appraisal that I talked about
I mean had it been an appropriate
building we have a huge affordable
housing Pro uh problem particularly in
that part of the state in oopy um um
there's a sober um there's a sober
living um group White Mountain White
Mountain I'm losing the the last last
part of it um and a lot of those people
could use housing when they come out of
that program I mean we just there's just
so many people who need housing so it's
it's hard to say how what kind of an
impact that would had but it's as you as
you saw it's 11,000 ft
building so that could have been a lot
of
Apartments again I'm going to remind the
committee if we could stay on topic
please uh represent stavis thank you Mr
chair U thank you for taking my question
um I like this bill I think it is is
needed uh I have a couple uh questions
about suggestions that I might have uh
for you to consider I'm can you move
your mic a little closer I'm to here
that better thank you yes thank you so
much um and one is would you consider
deleting uh Roman numeral one uh which
states the 15 days and just make Roman
numeral 2 Roman numeral one I'm sorry I
don't have I I I had a link for it here
can you can you tell me what that so
Roman numeral one is the um County
Commissioner shall give adequate notice
of a minimum of 15 days to the public
and I'm suggesting just delete that and
make Roman numeral to the county shall
provide notice of such sale in County
newspapers at least 30 days prior to the
sale etc etc just make that number Roman
numeral
one so you're just saying to swap them
no just no I'm saying to delete Roman
numeral one and make Roman numeral 2
one yeah I mean that I mean that's
basically that that um enables the
public to uh get requ to submit an
RFP represent stavis follow up and and
one more which is in line 20 after
um and shall be provided with a
reasonable opportunity for public
comment would you be amenable to adding
pursuant to RSA
91a which would somewhat kind of re in
that public comment to what is allowable
under
statute yes I mean again if people you
know um you know again we're trying to
to make an amendment so that people can
do up to three minutes without
interruption hoping I guess we have to
wait to see if that bill passes but yes
thank
you further comments or questions
representative power representative
priest could you throw off your mic
please thank you thank you m thank you
Mr chairman and um so I'm I'm looking at
the the bill language and I'm looking at
Roman numeral 1 starting on line 10 page
first page of the bill and then um Roman
numeral 2 and it's not clear to me what
the purpose of each section is and uh
just it seems to me and and clarify or
help me to understand it seems to me
potentially the wording uh in Roman
numeral 1 is that if there's a property
that
um is to be sold then there'll be a
public notice of just this is for sale
and then in Roman numeral 2 perhaps the
purpose of that section is that when a
sale you know a buyer is
identified and there's going to be the
sale that that will be um noticed is is
test
no turn it back on again and see just
yeah thank you Mr chairman um
perhaps someone or we could talk offline
but it seems to me that the first
section is there's it's like listing a
property like this properties for sale
and the in Roman numeral 2 that section
is we found a this is going to be sold
to this buyer for this price and that's
that purpose of notice of for that
section well it it shouldn't be it's
going to go to sale it should be that
it's I think the wording would be better
if say that there's there's that there's
coming to an agreement on a sale they're
approaching finality before any papers
are
don't just
on how about okay there we go uh
representative power I'll give give you
one more quick one I bring that up
because representative stavis had um
suggested some amendments to to make
things simpler
but I'm I'm I'm a little concerned by
deleting one if there's two purposes
here in the two Roman numeral sections
and by removing one you're going to
remove a purpose so that's that's all
I'm trying to point out thank you so
what I'll say is on the sections one and
two if maybe that is best handled
offline you guys can coordinate what you
want to do with that thank you further
questions
comments representative
Elward thank uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I'm
looking at Roman uh five M so the
Public's going to to be given
notice of the acceptance of the winning
bid and provided with opportunity for
public comment what is the purpose of
the public comment how is that going to
change anything or have an influence
on the acceptance of a winning bid is
your question how would public comment
change that how would public comment
have any purpose oh I think I think it
has a huge purpose because um again
people in our community were not I mean
in this particular case I mean I can
just tell you the rationale for it with
the charter school they felt it was
going to be um draining students from
the public school and weren't sure how
it was going to impact the public school
nearby so they had concerns about
selling you know to a charter school and
how it was going to impact public
education and I think that that those
were important points that should have
been made
public representative Elward F followup
thank you Mr chairman so would the sale
be contingent upon this public comment
period I I I don't think public comment
ever you know um um what's the word I'm
looking for I I I I think it can
influence let's put it that way I think
it influences if you I mean we've had
we've had instances where different
things happening in the in our County in
our communities where you have a room
full of people an auditorium full of
people
yeah I think that that impacts um
decision making I
do see no more uh represent Mr Clark go
ahead thank you Mr chairman uh I'm also
a member of the uh C County delegation
and
uh wasn't this generated this bill
because of the charter school of being a
charter school that went in there that
took the took over the building the
charter school I don't really understand
your question isn't this bill because of
a child of
school this bill is because of what
transpired in the sale of that building
which ultimately in this case went to a
charter school May I just do a
$1 wasn't the uh that building you're
mentioning that's on the National
Historic list and one of the agreements
that that building had remained the same
with the historic Courthouse within
inside of that and if it had gone to a
uh hotel or whatever you want to call it
housing that Courthouse would have been
destroyed in the historic value related
to it would have been gone I I'm not
sure I'm not sure that that is that is
how the historical um statute relates to
that building okay thank
you further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your
testimony don't forget to fill out a
pink card for me
I have one other pink card and that is
counties good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is Kate
Horan on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of counties uh the
association is opposed to this bill and
believes that the current process under
28a which requires as representative
yella pointed out agreement from the
County Convention is adequate and
already provides for public feedback
because it happens at a delegation
meeting that has public comment and
represent buroughs did also point out
that you are currently working a bill
through the process House Bill 1125 that
would put some more standardized
procedures around that public comment
but I did want to assure everyone on
this committee that counties already do
allow public comment at every meeting um
another thing we wanted to point out is
we are also confused by the language in
part one and part two it's not really
clear to us because if we're we may post
a building for sale but we may not be
able to sell it in 30 days so are we
putting it up for sale and then waiting
till we have an agreement to then post
it in the newspaper so it's that part is
just a little confusing to us as to how
how that all works around um we also did
want to draw your attention to line 17
through 20 of the bill which requires an
appraiser to evaluate the building
before it is sold counties as you all
know as members of your delegations have
a variety of properties some including
collapsed barns that just sit there do
we really need an appraisal for a
collapsed Barn that we're s selling to a
scavenger I don't necessarily think
using that fee for an appraiser is
necessarily the best use of County funds
um I will conclude my testimony there
but happy to take any questions but I
will just say I was not involved in the
Carol County situation so I can't answer
questions about
that thank you for your testimony
further com uh
questions I see none thank you very much
Miss
Horan uh we have no more pink cards um
the blue signin sheet has no names on
it so with that we will go ahead and
excellent okay all right so um we will
go ahead now and reopen the executive
session uh we will take the next one in
line we have a little
time uh that will be HB 1414 relative to
Gunstock area commission and ski resort
and hold on
yes we're going to wait for the clerk to
here
all right the clerk is ready to go so I
am going to
recognize uh representative kahill I
believe he may have an amendment
yes I'm going to be introducing an
amendment for representative Barbara
224-9548 introduces there a second on
that representative yala second would
you like to speak to uh your Amendment
or the amendment yes I'll speak to the
amendment as far as I um I know about it
it looks like there's just um a simple
change starting at at line 11 through
line
13 um changing how the percentage of the
um the 3% would be a gradual increase
instead of a instantaneous increase it
looks like they're amending it to um
gradually increase over the next few
years and she the amendment also deletes
section two and um from from the
original
Bill okay thank you very much do we have
questions or comments on
that representative
Gallagher um so I'm seeing we have
multiple amendments here does this um
sued the other ones we'd received or are
we um going to be considering this is
the amendment that has been introduced
now we will tackle this one and any
other amendments will be introduced if
905 seeing none we will ask the clerk to
call a
roll thank you uh Mr chairman Vice
chairman power no
representative Guthrie no clerk votes no
Representative lalis no representative
uh yella yes representative Kelly
award
yes representative Melvin
no representative kahill yes
Representative stavis
no representative Tetro no
representative carry no representative
Gilman no representative Fox no
representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks no
representative Howland no representative
Priest
No representative Frank no Mr chairman
yes
16 to uh four motion fails that motion
fails uh are there any others who would
like to introduce an amendment
representative y
Kella thank you I'd like to move uh
24924 do we have a second on
that I second the motion representative
kill seconds would would you like to
speak to your Amendment yes thank you um
I think there was a lot of
um
consternation um with some of the
language about increasing the amount of
money
and uh public testimony and video
recording and all of that stuff um so
this amendment seeks to do two things um
it eliminates all of that um and just
focuses on the forensic audit as that
seemed to be from the sponsors the most
important part of the
bill um and I also changed the effective
date to the beginning of the year
instead of 90 days after so that um it's
Mak sense of rolling every year um that
that it that year time frame starts at
the beginning of the year um I thought
that was important so I hope that um you
know this simplified Bill uh might even
if you don't support the bill as a whole
you might support the amendment of just
focusing this this uh discussion just on
the uh the forensic audit going forward
thank you thank you for the comments or
questions representative power thank you
Mr chairman um
while I understand um some people in the
county their interest in conducting a
forensic
audit we have in statute um the
provision or the requirement to conduct
an audit annually so the the
addition of a forensic audit done
randomly every 5 years clearly would be
an addition
to a a regular audit that's currently um
done
annually and to be clear a forensic
audit is special
audit um that's more of a deep dive into
the financial records to derive evidence
to be used in in a legal
proceeding and um the bellnap county
delegation it's my understanding that if
they wanted such an audit to be
conducted then they they could vote and
have one done so therefore requiring um
a forensic audit in RSA in addition to
the audit that's currently required in
statute to me is um an unnecessary
expense for for the county when there's
already a provision to do an audit and
I'm I'm uncomfortable with putting an
additional audit of that
level into statute and to my best
understanding that this is not in line
with normal practice so I for those
Reasons I'm unable to support this
provision in an amendment or in the
underlying Bill thank you further
comments representative Kelly hi thank
you Mr chairman um representative Kelly
pull pull that mic closer so we can hear
you I um would normally agree with your
assessment um but in this case I feel
that there is a lot I hate this um a lot
of um consternation amongst everybody um
a lot of problems um and I'm um I guess
unfamiliar once this amendment is dealt
with we'll be dealing with the
questions we're currently dealing just
with the amendment now once we get to
the underlying bill you can do that so
am I allowed to comment as opposed to
question at this point uh no no
okay unless you're commenting on the
amendment I'm commenting on my belief
that this amendment is valuable well
then speak to it
um I I tend to not like to speak so I
would rather not but um I have questions
like um I I'm wondering if someone can
answer how much property tax is paced on
uh is paid on lease properties at
Gunstock like ski club houses and
whatever um things like that that have
happened for so long that I think a
foren that got it is necessary and worth
the
expense thank you further comments or
questions sen
PRI thank you Mr uh chairman
uh and I have a question to the sponsor
of this again
my understanding is that all of the bill
would be wiped out and the new Amendment
would be put in so lines
one through 18 would be wiped out and
this would be in this place okay thank
you further comments questions
represent yes thank you this this
amendment is a replace all and uh so
this would be in the entire Bill all all
six glorious lines of it um
the I think that a little bit uh my
belief with that previous bill was that
there was um some political
ramifications about deciding who who
should be able to decide and and be able
to bring up dust um regarding the sale
of something with this I think we're
going the other way and saying that
there this is avoiding that dust up of
uh political uh personalities getting
involved in whether or not someone is
going to do an fin Financial uh forensic
audit um and uh so I think that in it in
and of itself is valuable and that this
is you know a
uh government own asset and it's very
important that the government knows that
it is
being
um handled properly proper
properly and so I think that that this
small investment to make sure that it is
um being run and um in an aboveboard
manner um is a safeguard for their asset
uh in the long term so I hope that
you'll be supportive so thank you
representative kahill thank you Mr chair
yeah I'd like to e echo my colleague
sentiments I think that just about every
publicly traded company out there
conducts audits of their corporations
for their shareholders and and I think
that this isn't just for the purposes of
Court this could be used in in that
setting but it it has other purposes as
well um it has the purp can be used for
the purpose of conducting a Better
Business and making more more money for
the owners of that business in this case
it's
yes representative
Elwood yes thank you Mr
chairman um I asked representative Bean
Harry Bean
if Gunstock had had a a fraud waste and
abuse policy and it was I was stopped or
talked to the lobbyist outside this
morning I asked him the same
question and I get no response it's my
understanding that they redid their
policies um after the debacle and that's
fine but I find it odd that people don't
understand what a fraud waste and abuse
it okay uh repres representative
McDonald uh thank you Mr chairman I'm
going to go along with our
representative Powers uh her opinion I
don't think we're here sitting in
conquer we should be managing Gunstock
Gunstock for all I know is very
successful if the people of the
residents of Bap County if they're not
happy with what the representatives do
they can vote them out if all the people
in bout County want a an audit um then
they get rid of the people that don't
want the audit but I certainly don't
want want this committee coming into my
business in cow County and telling us
what to do especially if friends have
got it it's very expensive if we're
going to tell them we're going to do it
we should be paying for it uh and I have
I have faith in all the members of the
delegation there seems to be a small
minority that are demanding this
forensic onit and I think it should stay
at the delegation level let them talk to
the other members let them talk to the
voters and they can decide within the
county whether they want to do this or
not thank you thank you further comments
or
questions representative priest
thank you Mr chairman I also agree with
uh representative McDonald and Power on
this I think a forensics audit is
just over the top and since they're
required to do an audit on a yearly
basis and they continue to do that that
should be sufficient if the people of
bnap County if the delegation feels that
this is not enough they can vote in a
motion to have a forensics a it done uh
for the uh ski
area repres
Davis thank you Mr chair um I agree with
representative Powers um summation of
existing law and would only seek to ask
if requiring this particular County to
do a forensic audit would be an unfunded
mandate unless un
unconstitutional
further comments or
questions seeing none I will make uh
make a comment
um I I am in in favor of this and I will
explain
why while a forensic audit is above and
beyond the the annual audit I I'd liken
it to the difference between every year
we file our income
taxes it goes in the IRS well nowadays
it's probably automated the computer
looks at it and looks for any
discrepancies and for the most
part it goes through that's that's your
annual audit a forensic audit is when
the IRS sees something and they go hey
wait a minute look at look at
representative
turcot's
uh return from uh 2023 we see an issue
with that representative turkot I get a
notice um please bring in all your
returns and receipts for the last three
years we're going to do a u a look into
your your tax returns that's what a
forensic audit is or the equivalent in
my
case let's not gloss over the issue here
in bellnap County with Gunstock all
right there's a history there and it is
political you can't get around it um I
originally approached both sides call it
sides whatever you want to call it
on this bill to see if there was some
way we could come out with um kind of a
middle ground where both sides would
finally kind of bury the hatchet on this
this is really in my opinion gotten out
of
control and the delegation is political
we deal with that in my County right
now it's very
political by putting in forensic audit
that's every five years it takes the
politics out of it and I think any time
that we can find in our rsas where we
can eliminate the political or the
personal issues with it I'm in favor and
I think this is one now if this turns
out to be such a bad
expense um which I honestly every five
years I do not believe it would be um
somebody can put in a u Amendment or a
bill the in the future years to remove
it I just don't see this as a a big
burden and quite honestly it might
actually eliminate some of the animosity
that continues to happen up in belnap
County so I I am in favor of this
um that's what I have for the comments
or
questions seeing none we'll ask the
clerk to call a
roll okay on 202
24924 okay thank you Mr chairman um Vice
Guthrie clerk votes no represent V
sales
no representative yella yes
representative Kelly very strong
yes I'll push down hard on the pen here
okay
excuse
me representative aood I'm sorry
yes representative Melvin no
representative kahill oh yes
Representative stavis no representative
Tetro no Representative krie no
representative Gilman no representative
Fox no representative Gallagher
no representative Hicks no
representative Howland no representative
Priest
No representative Frack no Mr chairman
yes motion fails uh 5 to
15 okay
five okay that motion fails so now we
are unless there are any other
amendments out there which I do not
believe there will
be so we are now back to the uh
basic bill as presented hb1
1414 do we have any motions on that
representative McDonald uh itl do we
have a
second representative howand second set
would you like to speak to
your
yes
as I uh spoke easier considering the
other amendments uh I think it's
something that the the delegation in
Bound up County can decide what they're
going to do and how they're going to run
the mountain uh I live in wo which is
just on the other side of the lake and
if heard nothing but great things about
how gun stock is being run and being
operated uh we've had a lot of bills
concerning this mountain and I think
they're on the uh the positive streak
and they should be able to run the M
they where they want to with uh the
delegation setting the standards and the
goals that the molon should should
should reach along with the uh
Commissioners and I ask you to support
the
itl thank you further
comments representa
power thank you Mr chairman um I have a
lot of comments but I'll just I'll just
limit it to to to one single one and
that is a reminder that the three
Gunstock oversight committees opposed
this bill the bellnap county delegation
voted 11 to4 to oppose the bill and both
the Gunstock area commission as well as
the bellnap County Board of
Commissioners voted unanimously to
oppose the
bill representative yella thank you I I
thank representative power for giving me
um all of the evidence for why I support
the bill um and those are uh very um
good reasons to to vote uh no on itl
thank you ref of kahill I would agree
with my colleague which is um rare but
um it's sad that uh we don't want actual
oversight um when we're pushing
oversight on so many other issues most
of the time but this is no no different
representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair we heard in
testimony that uh the
um this bill was not brought to the full
delegation in a a timely manner and I
did look at the uh meeting minutes for
the uh commission or the delegation in
question and it's true that um um the
notice of this was brought up at the
time of approving the agenda they have a
kind of funny way of doing business
where they announce the meeting and then
have an agenda and then they vote to
approve the agenda and this item was
pushed onto the agenda at that meeting
so there was no public notice that this
was going to be heard by the delegation
or the public at all so for that reason
uh just a a procedural error that made a
difference I can't vote for this
bill represent Galler so I kind of um
alluded to this in one of my questions
um at the Bill's hearing but um I
believe that the um that the results of
the previous election uh should be
interpreted as a referendum on this
whole issue and that we should respect
voters further
comments seeing none when the clerk is
1414 14 and 14 itl um Vice chairman
power yes representative guthy yes click
votes yes represent lales yes
representative Ella uh
no representative Kelly
no Representative aood
no representative Melvin yes
Representative
kahill
no representative stavis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
kry yes representative Gilman yes
representative Fox yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frank yes Mr chairman
to5 okay
15-5 uh is there objection to going on
the consent
calendar we have um couple of objection
objections so it will go on the regular
calendar who will be writing the
committee report for the itel motion
will that
be yeah I'll do it okay representative
McDonald will write the committee report
for itl
and representative Cahill will write the
committee report
uh opposing the all right with that that
yet okay um we still have a little bit
to go so why don't we continue on our
executive list uh let's go ahead and
open up the executive session on HB
101 relative to exempting the land and
buildings of masonic lodges from
property
taxation we'll open up that and I
believe we have a motion from
representative Elward yes I'd like to
make a motion to
[Music]
um itl House Bill
10001 do we have a second uh yes you do
from here representative y seconds would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Elber yes thank you Mr
chairman um House Bill 101 seeks to
specify that Masonic lodges and Masonic
Association are exempt from property tax
however they can already apply in um
their respective towns and cities and
some lodges are
exemptions further comments ments or
questions representative
McDonald I'm going to uh vote against
the itl uh as as she said the represent
said there are certain towns that are
allowing the exemptions but there are
communities that aren't um I'm not a I'm
not a Freemason uh my dad was and I did
a little bit of work on the history and
it was established back in 1717
1717 in England and some of the people
that are have been Masons father father
found in fathers George Washington Ben
Benjamin
Franklin uh the Roosevelt Franklin
Roosevelt Joe for Harry Truman Winston
Churchill daav Crockett Lewis and Clark
Charles Lindberg Buzz Aldren mosa Mark
Twain and the list goes on and on and on
and if anything I think the Mason groups
uh have gone to the top of the list as
far as uh getting any type of uh break
on their taxes I have a masonic temple
in my community U we have a dentist that
belongs he provides free uh dental work
to Veterans and also people that
unfortunately don't have the money to
have the dental work they also do a
breakfast on Sundays to make that
available to the public and a lot of
other things that they don't brag about
or they don't tell their Community about
uh but the two or 3,000 they may lose
paying the taxes in Wolf bro uh the town
gets more than a benefit enough of all
the services they provide and I think
it's a group that should be supported by
us just based on the uh the previous
membership and what some of these
you rep representative K yes I'm going
to be um voting against the itl um more
than any other bill that has came before
our committee I heard from my own
constituents um which was surprising um
and I overwhelmingly got the request to
support this bill so I will be
representative
Elward yes thank you Mr chairman um I
have a chart here
from
um Masonic Grand Lodge
website and whereas some towns with a
depending on the tax rate it ranges from
3,000 to you know just over
41,000 um that it could cost cost the
[Music]
$341,900 further comments questions
represent
priest thank you Mr uh chairman I agree
with my fellow colleague um that I think
this bill has unintended
consequences I agree that the Masons do
a lot for our
communities but so does the Elks the
Shriners you name the list and this will
just open the door for all of them to
ask for
exemptions and we the residential
property owners will have to pick up the
tab the differences for all this thank
you for the
comments represent
power thank you Mr chairman um I've
thought a lot about this bill and um I
could see both sides to to the issue and
my first comment is that it's my
understanding that charitable
organizations in the state that want to
be recognized as such need to file an
application with the Department of
Justice um under the charitable trust
Bureau and when I went to the doj
website and I looked I saw 367 page a
page of a spreadsheet with approximately
13,000 registered Charities and I only
found two Masonic lodges or associations
registered and in good standing so that
that's notable
um and that those would be two Masonic
lodges or associations did I say in New
Hampshire there there's many Charities
that are in state and out of
state A further note is the 2007 Supreme
Court decision in the case of Elder
Trust of Florida versus the town of
epson and basically based on um
testimony during the hearing that the
Mason's charters in their Charters
there's no enforcable obligation to
perform charitable functions so to
summarize my concerns uh in general are
this while the Mason principles are
commendable and they undoubtedly perform
some charitable
functions and that's part of their
nature and purpose the primary focus of
these groups is fraternal and it's
focused on a fraternal function rather
than being solely charitable and for
those reasons um I'm going to support
the motion of
itl Representative
Gallagher um so um like GRE MCN i' like
to First acknowledge that um yeah I
might not be aming myself but I have had
a masonic uh family member my
grandfather
was a Shriner which is a type of Mason
um with the Elkin's Lodge um but so that
being said um though as much as I loved
my grandfather I don't think we should
be giving um special handouts to um
specific groups like this um the New
Hampshire Constitution it says that
government's um instituted um not for
the private interest or Ament of any one
man family or class of men and I think
that uh this bill would be in violation
this further comments or
question okay seeing none I will make a
couple um I I will support the motion of
itl um and here here's the main reason
um in this committee I I try to be as
consistent on policy as as as as
possible and I mean it's difficult to do
it 100% of the time but we we I believe
we need to be consistent on our policy
right now there are over 15 or or 15
property tax
exemptions
listed um that a town can take advantage
of I don't believe we should be
extending that list because every
exemption that we
Grant somebody else has to pick up the
redistribution I contacted My Town last
year on a totally different issue and
asked the the young guy who runs our
administrative town he's awesome and I
said if all those exemptions didn't
exist what how much would the property
tax go down on on somebody who doesn't
climb any exemptions he goes I happen to
keep track of that and he sent it to Me
2 and a half% now that may not sound
like a lot
but take your property tax multiply it
by 2.5% and say that's a nice chunk of
change I would like to keep rather than
redistributing to other
entities
um I don't want to tie it exactly
to um charity work but if I had 2.5% of
my property taxes
back I could donate that into addition
what I already do on charity to a
charity that I want and not necessarily
what somebody else is doing
um so for that reason I will be
supporting the I itl I think it's a
principal issue it is a principal issue
for me um
it's hard to vote against the speaker
who's the Prime sponsor of this but
um I I told him very early on that I
can't support it he understood it and
he's probably watching now um but
um we got we got to vote principal and
not personalities so with that um I'm
done further comments
questions represent Gilman thank you Mr
chair uh I I know that in the uh
testimony was the
uh information that Masonic lodges fall
under a 501 C10 a charitable
organization as opposed to a
501c3 which has and it has to do with
their
uh I want um how they're organized and
it includes then the definition
definition uh charitable organizations
and under 501 C10 and that's what the
Masonic lodger Association also um
defines themselves as so I think it's
already possible for them to ask for uh
a tax
exemption further comments or
questions represent stavis
thank you Mr chair I will also be
supporting the itl on this bill I was
disappointed in the um when the bill was
presented that the bill does exempt
properties that the Masonic lodges May
rent um and I I remember asking the
question well how will The Lodges know
that those properties are not to be tax
exempt and the response was well of of
course they will know rather than Maybe
we should write that into the bill so I
I just see the um potential for
confusion and uh complexity around those
lodges that do have prop properties that
are rented at a
profit uh and um generally
speaking think that every tax exemption
that we Grant just moves that those tax
dollars onto someone else to have to
question
okay um seeing no no more comments
questions we'll ask the clerk to call a
roll and itail motion of
101 okay uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie
yes representative yella
yes representative Kelly
yes representative aood
yes representative Melvin yes
Representative kahill
no representative
stavis
yes representative
Tetro
yes representative kry yes
yes representative Gilman yes
representative Fox yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest
yes representative Frank
yes Mr chairman yes motion passes
17-3 thank you uh Mr clerk uh
representative Elward will be writing
the committer report uh it will is there
any objection to the consent
calendar seeing none it'll go on consent
representa Elwood will write the
committee report and with that we'll
close executive session on
hb11 now um we only have one more exec
and then our our next um Bill won't be
till one I think we if we can turn this
one out quickly representative Davis um
um then we the uh Subs who are here will
not need to be here anymore unless they
want to hang out with Municipal and
County the rest of the day so um let's
go ahead and do that um HB
1317 we'll open up the exec session on
that
and I
believe I believe I have an
amendment yes Mr chair I would like to
move Amendment
2024 859
H thank
you representative stavis is there a
second second representative Gilman
seconds representative stavis would you
like to speak
to thank you Mr chair uh the amendment
in hand um change uh substitutes for the
word for good cause shown for administ
ministrative clerical assessment or
valuation errors which makes the bill
ambiguity thank you for the comments and
questions representative
power thank you Mr chairman um with
regards to the amendment um I do
acknowledge that the words in bold are
more specific and therein lies my
concern so I had an extensive
conversation with a local assessor with
over 30 years of professional
experience and we discussed um the bill
and I asked him questions so that I
could understand um the bill and what
the bill is doing more clearly and um
part of the discussion revolved around
the the word good cause so my concern is
is removing good cause from RSA is
something that should not be taken
lightly for a number of reasons so
current statute allows municipalities to
Abate taxes for good cause shown under
RSA 76 colon 16 which is established to
be a demonstrable error in the
assessment calculation or a
disproportionate
assessment also good cause can also
um mean and it has also been established
to to to Encompass the showing poverty
or inability to pay
and notably there's also a full body of
case law surrounding um and based on
good
cause so my concern is is that this this
amendment while it is more clear and
more
specific um the words administrative
clerical assessment or
evaluation are eras it does not take
into account a very real um situation
where a
house there was a house in my
neighborhood for example that was
leveled due to a gas explosion or
another example
that is not enabled through this
amendment is a situation where a person
through no no fault of their own um has
an accident there's some type of a
mistake AK or a misfortune where they
may lose their job they're in an
accident that they they can't work
there's a medical um situation in in
which they they can't work or their
finances are are
depleted and they're unable therefore to
immediately pay their taxes and they're
in a very difficult transition period
the assessor that I spoke with explained
that they do everything to avoid
non-payment of taxes they will put
people on payment plans first and they
really Grant total discharge from the
payment of of taxes so my my concern is
is that again while this language is
flexibility to be able to Abate taxes
and it's removing the the local control
by the um assessors or the Selectmen who
who Abate taxes so for that reason I
don't support the
questions representative K I think the
amendment is just a common sense
Amendment and really strengthens the
bill it does a really fantastic
job repres represent
Davis uh thank you Mr chair just just
point out that um the bill does not
organizations other comments questions I
see none I will make some comments
um as you see at the top of the list I
was the one who actually put the
amendment in and I'm going to explain
why I talked with the original sponsor
representative
Maguire and if you will remember on line
11 it said he had struck in the word
shall and put in the word may um as I
spoke earlier on a different bill I
think where we can take up take out the
subjectivity of political and personal
issues I think we should do that anytime
we can and the testimony that was given
on the the situation that brought this
up was not so much a shall or a may but
it was the length of time that was
required um when the request was uh
they gave a request for additional
information and they couldn't find for
some reason they couldn't find the
records in time so I explained to him I
said isn't it better that we actually
extend the days rather than the mayor sh
again shall eliminates the the subject
yes at the end of line 11 you'll see
that it was struck out unless it is
found that such requests were
unreasonable again again that's a very
subjective line unreasonable who
determines what's unreasonable what is
unreasonable you know again that's in
the eye Beholder I will remind some of
you won't remember because you weren't
here um or no everybody was here last
ter um there was a representative Smith
brought forth a similar
bill because of two court issues that
had happened in New Hampshire one was in
Berlin and one was I believe was in this
town of O and the Berlin one was
interesting or Illuminating in that the
Selectmen in the town basically used
this clause for good cause shown and
basically cut themselves a deal Abad
their property taxes so where we can
eliminate the subjectivity um I think
that's good line 13 and that's what we
do for good cause shown that was the the
Clause that they used to uh um try to
give themselves or a relative of an
abatement and again remember this is on
abatement of
taxes um and so that's why we ended up
with the administrative clerical
assessment or evaluation
errors so I I am in support of this I I
I think it takes a subjectivity in the
political personalities out of it and uh
you know if it's found to be in the
future that
uh it it creates issues I I'm sure
somebody can bring bring forward a
another bill
representative Hicks who looks like you
want to speak thank you Mr chairman I
was recently made aware of a an
organization in a town where the
computer um there's a computer error and
was overcharging an
organization um so that organization
under this would be we wouldn't have to
worry about whether it was good cause
because it was a some sort of evaluation
error based you know in the
algorithm or computer program so I think
that this helps with that thank you
forther uh represent
PRI just a point of clarification we're
voting on Amendment 2024
d859 is that correct that's correct okay
thank
you represent thank you Mr chairman I I
would also like to add
that in my conversation with the with
the assessor he he did comment that if
some someone um is concerned about Bad
actors or alleges a bad decision that
there are in fact currently ways to look
into it and um I have in my notes
something about an OS order but
unfortunately I didn't write down what
OS means but my point is is that we
already have the tools that we available
to us to to look into um what the
chairman described as as a concern and
so um
yeah I just wanted to to to to um
provide that
represent
sorry uh thank you Mr chairman when I
first
heard talk in the hallway about this
bill it was something
about uh charitable organizations or a
church where the um administrators are
getting very
for good cause shown was somehow a
reason or or that the being old and
misplacing papers and you know being
disorganized was somehow a a a good
reason
this use of good cause shown thank
you represent
McDonald Mr chairman we passed a bill uh
early that discussed this topic and I'm
wondering how this bill is going to
affect the topic or the previous bill
passed um which we talked about as uh
representative all was talking about the
the groups of smaller churches out in
the woods the school houses out in the
woods where the folks have got trouble
getting these documents together now
wouldn't this bill or this amendment got
that and requireed them to have
everything churned in within 60
days
uh I'm not familiar with the the issue
that you guys are actually talking about
I'm
I'm I don't
recall representative
Alward um thank you Mr chairman this
this references religious educational
and charitable
organizations so if a masonic lodge is
not registered with doj as a charitable
organization is that what you're trying
to
say you want me to answer
that I I you all have me totally
going as long as we can speak to the
questions seeing none Mr clerk can you
could we call a role on this
please okay
uh 1317 Amendment 2024
FN uh Vice chairman and
power point of
clarification so we're voting on The I
didn't hear what you said we're voting
on the amendment 0859 H correct that's
correct
no what is it I'm sorry no can I just
0859 thank you uh Representative guthe
no colleer votes no Representative lales
no uh representative Kella
no representative Kelly
yes representative
award
no rep representative Melvin
no representative kahill
yes representative stavis
yes representative
Tetro
yes representative krie yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Fox yes representative
Gallagher uh yes representative Hicks
yes representative Howland yes yes
representative priest
yes representative Frank
yes and Mr chairman
to7 do we have a motion on HB
1317 as amended representative
stavis thank you Mr chair I would like
to move out to pass as amended on HB
kahill I'm assuming since the bill is a
total replacement you're good very good
repres
yella thank you um I just don't see the
need for this um bill in its entirely
and it's an entirety I don't
um I think that wasn't enough of an
issue shown um that they were not able
to do what they should have done or that
there's some abuse or anything I don't I
think that um I think there was uh a
reference to by representative McDonald
about a prior Bill about extending stuff
and making making people be able to um
kind of uh get exemptions or
get um without following the
timeline um and I feel like this is just
another example of of you know ex
extending it and making it easier for
people to get um in in this case um
abatements
and uh so I think that that is I think
that there's no problem with that
process right now and so I'm going to be
voting against this so thank you could
everybody who is not speaking please
mics thank you represent
St thank you Mr chair um I I think it
it's not constructive to conflate one
bill with another bill um especially
when the subject matter is actually
quite different uh and and so I would
urge members if I may to focus on this
bill ought to pass as amended and not
try and relate it to any previous bill
that we have voted on thank you thank
you further comments seeing
representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman I will be
voting uh for a to pass as amended
because I think um this bill as amended
it really clarifies and it gives just
extensions of time for the uh terriable
institutions to comply with the state
thank
you thank you seeing no more comments
questions when the clerk is ready could
we call the rooll on
hp13 17 OTP as
amended okay uh Vice chairman
power no representative Guthrie no click
votes no representative
VES
I'm going to vote
Yes okay uh represent youra uh that's a
hard
no okay representative Kelly yes
representative
awards
no great representative Melvin
no representative kill
yes representative Davis yes
yes representative Gilman yes
yes representative Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative PR
yes representative Frank yes and Mr
chairman yes motion passes 14-
six okay with that it will not go on
consent we go on the uh regular
calendar uh representative stavis I
believe you will write the committee
report for the
otpa uh who wants to write The Minority
Report do we have any
takers seeing none I guess it'll go
without a Minority Report I'll
McDonald okay with that we'll close a
hearing on HB 1317 exec session that
completes all the exec bills so those of
you who stood in thank you very much as
I said you can welcome to come back and
join us but you don't have to uh we will
p.m.
okay welcome back everybody we're going
to get going on our next hearing uh in
front of us is uh HB
Amendment uh 2024
0688 H which is a full Bill
replacement uh rep representative
Rochford I see you are in the gallery
and we'll be introducing the
bill hearing is
open thank you Mr chairman and uh
members of the committee first of all I
do again want to thank you for
entertaining this um this is a a a
replace all non main Amendment and I do
recognize and appreciate uh the uh the
extent that the chairman has gone
through to uh and the committee to to do
this so I want to thank you for that um
I do have a constituent here who will be
speaking I'm actually in the middle of
an executive session so my chairman has
been very gracious to uh let me jump out
for a minute but I have to run back
as I think I might have mentioned the
wrong
Amendment uh do you have in front of you
805h yes
805 so uh the amendment is 2024
805h not the one that I previously
mentioned okay continue yes thank you so
I am going to my constituent is here
this was ultimately the she was the
impetus for this um so when I have to
jump out to go to Executive session she
will be uh available to testify and
answer any of the detailed questions but
this came about
um um locally uh in in our town where a
gaming uh
facility um wanted to come to town and
um you know there was no in the state of
New Hampshire you have to get a license
from the the lottery for a charitable
gaming facility and the license is is uh
uh issued and then depending on local
zoning um that facility can or can't
operate and the
various things that come with zoning uh
one of the things though that we found
out that really was different than
previous gambling bills and I'm not
anti-gambling um you know but what I am
is is very local very pro- local control
and what we found was that uh when the
state permitted Kino in municipalities
the municipality could vote whether to
allow Kino or not to allow Kino um and
uh that seemed to be very popular
sometimes do it sometimes don't but when
it came to games of chance and
historical horse racing that local
option uh was not was is not available
uh I can only guess that it perhaps was
an oversight um I know that this the hrh
charitable gaming came about during the
the pandemic uh or some of those aspects
of that came about during the pandemic
when things were U uh not as they seem
so that's really what this this bill
entails it allows for a local option
just like similar to Kino for um
historical horse racing uh in games of
chance it allows that uh if if the if
the town votes to permit that activity
um it can revoke that if no facilities
open up within a certain time period so
if they permit the the the activity and
three years goes by and there's no
facilities that open up the town can
then revote to revoke that uh um um uh
permission now one thing I do want to
note out note is that this we did I did
work very closely with my constituent
and with OS again another another shout
out to OS because they really worked
long and hard to do a number of drafts
with this but one of the things that
they pointed out that may cause some
confusion and and and I'll let the
committee decide is if you look on page
two um I'll I'll give you this example
it's it's found on page three as well
line
five and line
16 um line three starts off the
municipality has voted to allow the
operation of historic horse racing
machines and if no facility allowed to
operate historic horse racing machines
pursuant to this section or which was
permitted prior to July 1st
2024 there's no permits that are issued
um there are licenses that come from the
state of New Hampshire um and then it
goes on to say prior to July 1 2024 has
begun operation within 3 years of the
grant of permission so the municipality
would Grant permission but they don't
give permits so there may be some you
know changes of those words that maybe
uh add some clarity and that was OS had
suggested that as well and I think I
gave the chair uh a copy of that um but
that's that's really what it is and uh
again I'm going to ask my cons if if the
chair would allow my consistent to come
up and and and testify at this point um
I would allow her to to take it from
here and answer any questions that the
committee may have she's really done a
lot of research on this and is well
versed in this topic so just
procedurally uh we will allow the other
representatives to speak first sure and
then we will go to the other individuals
uh are there any questions uh
representative your representative power
thank you Mr chairman I understand that
you need to get to an executive session
so I'll make it really quick in your
bill introduction you've you used the
word facility a number of times my
question is could you clarify what a
facility is I'm not a gambler but I do
am aware that there's Kino in my town in
a Chinese
restaurant so that being said it is also
my understanding that historic horse
racing again I'm not a gambler is is
more suitable for to be in a venue of a
casino is that correct or incorrect can
you like square that with the use of
facility versus Casino again I think
that and and I'll let my constituent
again if you could also Reserve that
question for her as well and she can
maybe um contradict me but but uh uh and
that and that's not necess again she's
done a lot of research on this but when
when we look at facility the intent is
you know a large scale facility casino
type type thing and and again that's why
you know and you bring up a good point
with the facility the casino we want to
raise the bar a little bit when we when
we worked on this legislation on how the
this permission is revoked we wanted to
raise the bar in that it just can't be
on a whim I mean these are facilities
that have made considerable investments
in the community um buildings Capital
licensing employment U so these
facilities I.E casinos um that's that's
the intent of that again it's the other
intent is not to be able to pull the rug
out from under these folks who have put
millions and millions of dollars into uh
communities representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
question sorry I came in a little bit
late so maybe you've already addressed
this um what is the need the the rush I
guess for this bill um and why was why
why wasn't it just filed during normal
uh Bill filing time yeah this came about
uh as Midstream in we discovered that
there wasn't a local option for uh
casino type gambling Kino there's a
local option municipalities can vote
whether they want it or not our our
local um um town uh has a casino likely
coming in uh and some of the residents
in town wanted see what you know what
could be done as far as gauging the
community's support for this you know we
have Kino The Kino uh is a very simple
referendum if you will that can be put
on a ballot that can gauge us sport when
when when the folks from our community
went to do that in Littleton they found
out there's really no mechanism to
determine whether or not the the
community wants it or not um and as you
as you as you are aware um you know
gambling in casinos you know it's it's
an emotional issue it can be a hot
button issue I mean there's some social
concerns that are brought up uh law
enforcement um you know those are all
issues that we've heard about uh uh in
my Committee in Ways and Means um so you
know I Feel Again local as a locality um
who are going to be affected by this
it's important that the municipalities
have a you know at least can can can can
live up to the precedent that was set in
Kino representative
lales
yes thank you for taking my question
um I I feel very
uh dumb on this issue but um could you
define the the phrase historic horse
racing
machines I I I think of a carnival where
you have a you know horses running
across and squirting water into the
mouth
of but what is a historic horse racing
machine prior to my election to the New
Hampshire house I probably would have
been on the same page as you um but uh
and I know there are folks from the
industry here that if I get this wrong
they can uh they can they can um correct
me but a historical horse racing machine
is really you know if it would
assimilate I I don't like to use the the
term I don't it's a well for lack of a
better term it looks like a slot machine
in that's it's it's its uh dimensions
and the way it works but what it does is
it takes historical horse races over the
course of several years it makes them
Anonymous so you don't know where the
race was you don't know who the horse
was and so you can't determine who the
winner is and and then you can bet on
that
race um to get an outcome so you know in
the
2012 running of the you know Saratoga
Springs horse race that has 12 horses in
it you wouldn't know when it was you
wouldn't know where it was you wouldn't
know the names of the horses but you
could bet on the outcome of that and
it's a it's a game of chance uh where
you could win if uh if if you won that
that race and and again I apolog there's
folks from the industry behind me if I
have butchered that uh um uh they'll let
me know but that's
I can tell you at the 30,000 foot level
that's that's what it is it's no no
squirt guns no popping
balloons thank you uh so there's no
chance follow up Mr chairman follow up
there's no chance for somebody like me
to go in and say Ah that's
Secretariat no I I think that the folks
running these have uh made sure that
they're they're not going to they're not
going to lose out to somebody with a a
your further questions for
representative
roord representative Gilman thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking for
taking my question uh last year uh there
was established a study
Commission on charitable gaming
including the newly authorized
historical horse races and this is to
study the effect of recent changes and
their report is due in November so why
are we doing this now before that report
comes yeah that's a good question and
and they do meet regularly and they were
just they just met on uh Monday um and
I'm told that this could be an Avenue
for them to to look into in the future
as far as I know this is not on their
agenda uh right now um that's not saying
it it might not be uh before November
but um yeah that's that that commission
is ongoing in their work okay thank you
further questions
Mr chair thanks for spending your I know
how tight your your uh time is with your
committees
um simple question I
think the statement on on the bill says
that the amendment gives municipalities
the option to operate historic horse
I I wonder why I'm curious why the order
is that way and if we pass this does
this
legalize uh all games of chance in the
state of New Hampshire um I mean games
of chance is uh it's a regulated
industry already in the state of New
Hampshire um Lottery oversees that you
have got a license
uh the background is to to get a license
is is is is an extensive process um this
would not expand the scope of games of
chance in in New Hampshire as as a
matter of fact it would just do the
opposite will allow municipalities to
keep J games of chance out of their
choose further questions representative
stavis
thank you Mr chair so if games of chance
are already allowed in New Hampshire and
regulated by the gaming
commission then how is it that we are
giving towns a local option to allow
them they are already allowed shouldn't
it read to not
allow well and actually if you look at
the if if you look at the the bill yes
and local option
would on um
page one one line 25 it's very specific
the wording that would go on the ballot
the wording of the question shall be as
follows shall we allow the operation of
horse racing machines within the town or
city so you're right as it is now um it
is allowed but this this would allow
that question would allow a negative
vote of in the negative
no further questions
represent
FR thank you Mr chair um as a novice I
need a little bit of
explanation can you explain the
difference between a historical horse
horse race machine and a game of chance
yes so historical horse race machine is
a it's a it's a machine designed for a
specific purpose using a specific set of
data I.E um historical horse races a
game of chance could be Blackjack it
could be uh cards it could be other
types of electronic and those those
would be physical um uh games uh it
could be other electronic type games as
well um so that's the difference between
and and the reason why they're separated
there are they are delineated in the law
separately um so that's why it's
representative Elwood thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I'm looking at lines 23 and 24
on page
1 which talks about
um publishing notice of a public Hearing
in a newspaper of General circulation at
least 7 days before the
you've limited it to potentially only
seven days before the
hearing yeah I I think and my
constituent can comment on this if I get
it wrong I believe that that that
wording was taken out of the Kino local
option so we wanted to make it as as
close to The Kino local option language
as as we could so we're not creating a
whole bunch of a bunch of new law um so
I believe that's where that's where that
came from followup sir go ahead um
and many times in statute it will
mention publishing public hearings on a
website is that not includ that's not
included here so it's not required by by
Statute here and again going back to
where Kino that was mimicking Kino but
that I mean you're right I I I I don't I
read I read my news online rather than
in in a physical newspaper my myself so
maybe it's time to get with the times
and and and make those changes while
we're at it thank
you for the
questions I just have one that might
clear sure a lot of this stuff up for
everybody is it fair to say that um the
wording that you have put in for local
option historic horse racing
machines and local option games of
chance is basically the same language
taken out of the Kino local option
section and applied with minor edits
absolutely and and you're absolutely
right and I say I would say the only
difference is we raise the bar on how
hard it would be to revoke the privilege
because buying a $5,000 Keno machine or
or whatever it is to put in a Chinese
restaurant is a much different
investment than putting $20 million into
a a new physical building um so we
wanted to raise the bar with that
perfect thank you all right seeing no
more questions thank you you very much
on to your committee work thank you uh
next up uh again we we have to take them
in a specific order next we have rep
David
Paige thank you Mr chairman and uh thank
you to representative Ros for to for uh
alerting me to this uh amendment that he
was putting
forward uh he invited me to uh help him
out with this amendment because
Littleton and Conway are kind of along a
similar path right now Conway might be a
little bit further along we were very
surprised to discover that a casino was
coming to town um I want to First really
Echo a couple points that he made and um
the first being this is not about
whether you're Pro or anti- gambling
this is about whether you believe that
it's the municipality's decision as to
whether to to allow a casino in
town um the other piece I want to Echo
is that we're not trying to undermine
anyone's investment so where we are in
Conway we are pretty much resigned to
the fact that a casino is going to be in
town and I'm okay with that I've made
peace with that um but I think that this
this amendment will help other towns not
have the situation that we have had in
Conway um I think our casino that will
be coming to town will be grand
grandfathered in um if this amendment
were to pass and the bill were to
pass for me the and this kind of speaks
to representative Gilman's question
about why
now um for me the reason to deal with
this now is that this is an issue that
towns are facing on the ground right now
this year um you know it's happening in
Littleton it's been happening in Conway
um and the the Crux of the question is
should we get to
decide and in my particular
town we have had Kino on our warrant
multiple times and the town has
consistently voted that
down um our Charter uh I disagree with
this language in the charter but our
Charter says that gambling is a social
evil and should be
discouraged and yet here we are in this
situation where my constituents didn't
really have a mechanism for um voicing
their opinion on this and maybe they
would have surprised me and said yes but
for me the Crux of the issue is who gets
to
decide um and I would hope that uh that
you would support this amendment I I
think it will it will help it will help
towns uh who face similar situations
like mine um to just be able to have a
voice in this process I'm happy to take
any questions yeah representative
status thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question question um there
is a casino currently under construction
in Lebanon New Hampshire which I
represent y uh which came before the
planning board where there was ample
opportunity for public comment was there
no such planning board hearing in
Conway there absolutely was and I won't
I won't bore you with the blowby blow
but it became very contentious and um
subject of some some potential lawsuits
um the uh my understanding is that the
um that the permitted use was as an
indoor amusement was what was being
argued um but that was that was
contentious and there was not an
agreement go ahead um thank you for
taking this follow-up question so when
our planning board heard this
application um and we had a similar
discussion amongst our members and
members of the public the response from
the planning director
was the state has allowed
it you must allow it
[Music]
um so I guess I'm I'm going to ask a
different version of that same question
is to why now I mean this seems to be a
settled question they go before planning
boards the public has a right to comment
but and and believe me I'm not happy
about this I don't particularly want a
casino in Lebanon but it is the
law and where do we stop if we give a
local option to prohibit one business
and not other businesses I'm not happy
to ask that question but I'm asking
it sure um well I I guess I guess for me
the issue is that it does seem to be
settled law and do we like it the way it
is and that's and that's why I'm here um
and in terms of where do we stop I would
say
that gambling businesses are
qualitatively a different kind of
business than most businesses um and do
we agree that they that they should be
regulated in exactly the same way as any
other business I think Kino gives us a
good point of comparison and I think
that's why this amendment in this
amendment uh representative rfor chose
to mirror that existing statute um I
would say that's a
comparable um that's a comparable uh
activity and it makes sense to me that
way representative uh y Kella go
ahead thank you uh thank you for taking
the question um in your testimony and
you were talking about your um was it
the master plan or your Charter your
Charter and how they um demonize
um would
you um believe that that the that that
kite type of bigotry toward this this
type of establishment is what the state
cuz we have we only voted for for hor
historical horse racing in the last few
years that we we passed that knowing
that there was no local option so that
we can that we can have that fight back
on against that bigotry um and say no
these are a business just like any other
business and should not be discriminated
just because of the type of business
they have or do you think that that um
in your your experience that that was
just not discussed sure
so first let me say and I believe I said
this in my testimony I disagree with
that language and I think we should
change it I think the language is quite
strong the reason I raised it is because
I think it establishes sort of a a
temperature of the Town um I wouldn't
characterize it as bigotry um but I
would but
um you know I
I I guess my my question that I would
pose in return is is is there a
difference between a gambling EST
establishment and other kinds of
establishments in terms of the cost to
the community for example so I would
just
um I guess I would just turn around and
say do we believe that it's a business
business further comments
questions seeing none thank you very
much repres
Stringham uh thank you very much I'm
Jerry Stringham I represent Lincoln
Woodstock in Easton um uh first um I I
did sign on to this amendment uh I was
also in Ways and Means from 2018 to 2020
when um when historic horse racing was
first brought actually didn't pass uh
during that term so first uh let me
comment a little bit about what historic
horse racing is a historic horse racing
is a slot machine with a different back
engine um the uh a slot machine is the
the winning combination is based on
random number generators and what shows
up on the screen historic horse racing
uh really really was created in a way to
be able to bring slot machines into the
state without calling them slot machines
so uh what when you you look and you
play it it looks just like it you set
the thing on autop pick your your horses
and you can play uh a game in 8 seconds
and push the button again and it comes
up and the screen looks like it's got
three Aces and two kings you're a winner
it doesn't you don't see a horse you
don't you're not betting on the odds
you're not seeing whether the dirt is uh
it's a muddy track or a clear track the
way that almost all the games are played
is exactly like a slot machine uh so one
of the reasons why um uh there wasn't a
lot of discussion when this was first
going on about where else to put it is
because the original Bill limited
historic horse racing machine to the
established Gaming facilities in the
state it's still part of this uh
committee work that's being done now is
whether whether we want to extend it or
not uh it has the ability a historic
horse racing machine assuming the
Lottery Commission comes up with a way
to license it properly and control it
properly to be used anywhere a slot
machine could be used and uh during a
week off I was in Texas I went into a
gas station they had three slot machines
in there and so you know I don't know
what the long-term thing is uh for for
this and this possibility right now uh
people are are in part probably because
of the extensive use and and Financial
potential of having these slot machine
like devices in a gaming facility that
um uh you know there's an expanded
interest in in opening new Gaming
facilities like the one in Conway like
the one in Lebanon and who who knows
where else in the state um and uh so I I
really think that the idea of of having
a local vote uh to allow this kind of
facility and this kind of machine to
come in was something that wasn't being
uh considered because it was kind of
already limited uh significantly there
was house there bills this term uh that
we voted on whether to limit the number
of new facilities or have an unlimited
number and so on so um you know I I uh
you know our towns voted both on ke on
Kino and both uh Lincoln and Woodstock
they had votes on that they had had
debates and made decisions
I think the the uh uh the experience of
having a slot machine like device
compared to Kino is very different and
you know the town may may vote the same
way they they voted to allow each of
them there's I think two Kino machines
in one town and one in the other I think
having the debate and the public
discussion of it was a very healthy
process uh for the state and under for
people to understand what's in there so
um uh
you know that that I I think the timing
uh is it's pretty urgent because of
what's going on um you know the out of
some of the out of state Gaming
facilities are being or some of the
Gaming facilities are being acquired by
out ofate uh companies or at least the
the uh stock of them is uh part of the
original uh limitation was that you know
remain uh New Hampshire businesses so uh
but now they're having different
shareholders so that's uh
um it's Le it's legal and permitted
around what we have I um I think it's um
you know critical that the towns be able
to decide whether they want slot machine
or slot machine like devices uh which
are called historic horse races uh and
um uh that's why that's why this uh
amendment was brought forward at this
time thank you representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for for taking my question so I
understand that historic horse
racing can and is it can be placed in a
casino proper what's not clear to me is
with if this bill were to become law and
I understand it's enabling
legislation can these
historic horse racing can historic horse
racing be placed in like a gas station
or a convenience store or a restaurant
I'm just I'm trying to understand where
these games would be um available is it
just in a a a casino or can they be
placed in
other businesses well this this bill
does not change where what type of
facility could have historic horse
racing as I said when the original bills
were passed they were limited to orig to
uh to the nonprofit gaming centers they
kind of call them that because uh every
week uh there there's a nonprofit of the
week that's affiliated with a gaming
facility and they get uh a donation
based on basically a percent of the cut
from from the uh individual gaming
facility and there's some in conquered
and you know big one over over in
Seabrook and so on um so
you know we've seen some expansion on
where historic horse racing would be
allowed basically new Gaming facilities
which is on top of what was first passed
which originally kind of gave gave the
existing Gaming facilities uh a monopoly
or an algop I guess based on on
facilities that were already um licensed
and approved and now it's expanding so
where that expansion goes uh this bill
doesn't change that at this point this
just this just says uh towns have the
right to to um allow it into their town
or
not so you look a little confused but so
representative yell thank you
uh you mentioned that you uh were in uh
the State House when when uh historic H
horse racing was was passed did you
support that effort uh so uh actually I
was not here when it was passed I was
here it was uh substantially discussed
uh in Ways and Means from 2018 to 2020
or that that by anym and um uh in
general I wasn't supportive of historic
horse racing as the bill was written
because I I didn't think I thought they
were slot machines and I I I didn't and
think if we were going to have slot
machines they should be licensed to
smaller facilities and the State state's
take should be substantially higher than
than we'll get from these
machines so represent s thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um speaking of ways and
means I have my questions I mean I
understand why this amendment is coming
to us because it's enabling legislation
but I also understand the extensive
discussions that have taken place in
ways and means and I'm
wondering
what what thread could be drawn
between the passage of this should it
pass and the diminishment of some of the
means coming into the state in the
future and and has that been a
conversation that's been happening with
the fiscal folks or is this completely
divorced from that
conversation yeah so I mean I'm I'm the
clerk of finance committee 3 this year
so I'm not in ways and means for for for
this part of the discussion um so
um representative it's okay to say I
don't know yeah so I don't think I can
help you there further
questions seeing none thank you very
much for your testimony thank
you uh next step Rick Newman New
operators thank you Mr chairman um I
appreciate the opportunity to testify
today my name is Rick Newman I'm a
lobbyist for the New Hampshire
charitable gaming operators Association
and um we do not support this amendment
as written uh for several reasons that
I'll go into but I'm going to I will
also try to be brief I want to respect
your time I want to start I guess by
answering some of the questions that
have been asked so charitable gaming
what we commonly refer to as games of
chance was adopted in
2006 by House Bill 1744 sponsored by
representative Ken
Wier and I I recall at that time that
bill was was uh presented it was in
Edna and there was discussion in the
subcommittees there were several
subcommittees there was discussion about
a local option uh portion going into
that bill it was discussed as I recall
at least two or three times um and the
the decision was made not to do that so
the bill passed in
2006 in 2018 or so when the second
attempt to pass historic horse racing
was made uh the bill was introduced
heard by Ways and Means to allow
historic horse racing I want to step
back just a second understand that under
the law today in order to have historic
horse racing you have to have a games of
chance license so to answer to your
question representative power that you
have to have a what is called a game
operator employer license now while the
current state of the situation in New
Hampshire is that everyone who has a g
goe game of of game operator employer
license has what we would all commonly
call a
casino uh the fact of the matter is if I
owned a restaurant I could go get a goe
license and put Blackjack and a crap
table in my banquet room okay uh that
has been done in the past and there have
been places that did that we don't
currently have anything like that now uh
so in order to have historic horse
racing you have to have a
goe in 2000 I'm I'm trying to do this
from memory cuz I I apologize I didn't
research it the question of a local
option on instor course racing was taken
up by the house it was a floor amendment
I want to say representative Mary Beth
walls uh sponsored it uh it was uh it
was in a session prior to co so I think
it was
2019 and it was defeated by the house
the house also by the way that year
defeated historic horse racing
legislation when it was passed in 20 21
there was no Amendment offered to make a
local option okay so I I set that as a
as a ground just to to say this in since
the passage of historic horse race there
have been significant Investments by
various game operator Employers in
bringing what we will call Charity
casinos to the various
communities that investment ranges from
anywhere from
probably on the low side I would say
would be one in Hampton Beach where they
probably put about $2 million in there's
one being constructed in Nashville right
now where I don't have any inside
information but I've read in the paper
the total investment is about $240
million so this is a significant
investment so get that gets us to our
concern about this
language we would not be opposed for
looking forward to having a local option
for historic horse racing um we do have
of course great concern about the way
this particular language is worded
because we're not convinced that it
absolutely grandfathers everybody who's
has an ongoing investment we would want
to make sure that that that language was
very carefully reviewed and put into
place so that no one not only no one who
currently is operating but no one who's
currently in let's call it the pipeline
and let me explain
that this house has passed Senate Bill
112 as amended and I believe in your
last session you also passed and I don't
have the bill number but it was another
bill out of ways and means that had
identical language to Senate Bill 112
and what those one of the provisions of
those two bills was that you extended
the current
moratorium on new facilities for 7 years
except there is an exception
any uh applicant that's already in the
lottery between who appli between
January 1 and I think it's October 18th
of
2023 those applicants should they end up
getting a license would also be eligible
for historic Horse Rising as I said that
bill no two bills have passed with that
l language in it those people even the
ones in the application process have
made a significant investment going
through that very vetted process and we
would want to make sure that they and
the current game operators are would not
come be subject to a a local option um
so given that the reality is there's not
going to be a flood I now neither bill
has become law so we know that I feel
fairly confident that that language in
some form is going to pass this session
and the governor who has previously
vetoed an extension of the moratorium in
Senate Bill 51 which he did last year
has indicated he would sign this new
language this new legislation because it
took care of businesses that were
already investing in the and I don't
want to I I I don't have any authority
to speak for for the governor but based
on his veto message he had said he
vetoed Senate Bill 51 because there were
other businesses that were already
looking into this and he felt they
needed to be protected so given all of
that I guess our basic testimony is
there isn't a need a rush to pass
language now the gaming study commission
does in fact have this on their agenda
in fact they just discussed it on
Monday um I know they're going to have
further discussions about it and um
there is I believe it appears a support
on the commission to come up with some
language that would put a local option
in place going forward and as I said as
long as the so one last thing it's just
so you know so there are 14 original
game operator
employers um they include Lebanon and
Conway and there are we've been told by
the Lottery that the potential new
applicants that would qualify under the
language passed by Senate Bill 112 the
total number of that is five that and
and and not we don't know if all five
will eventually get a license but if
they all did you would be looking at 14
current and potentially five new
facilities so given all of that we just
feel like it's um doesn't need to be
rushed and we would like uh and we think
the wording of this language is
areas uh one last thing I would say
there is also and this is again I'm not
trying to complicate things but like for
instance in the town of Salem there is
currently a game operator
employer but we also know that one of
the five applicants is a second game
operator employer that would go into
Salem and if this bill passed it would
appear that the one there now would not
need local approval maybe but the second
one would and so that again it's just
it's a complication it's one of those
things that legislation will you get
down into the nitty-gritty you got to
really work on to make sure that you're
doing what you think you want to
do representative
yell thank you thank you you've
convinced me that this is a bad idea but
as far as the amendment
um I have a question about kind of your
testimony and how
um so historical horse racing is just
one of kind of many different games of
chance that someone could have and if
you
have that operator license you could
choose to do a whole range of them um is
is if that is correct the the local
option is to just ban one of those those
many uh options that that could be used
on the floor of that gaming
establishment is that my is that correct
is that my understanding if the first
part of the bill were adopted by a local
community the answer to your question is
yes the second part of the bill would
allow a facil a local community to ban
games of chance entirely and just to let
me explain a complication in order to
have historic horse racing for instance
you have to have a game of chance
license those are two separate licenses
they they have different criteria to
apply for let's suppose a community
adopted allowing historic horse racing
but did not adopt allowing games of
chance well then you nobody could have
historic horse racing in that Community
because they can't have games of chance
further
questions seeing none I have one it's a
kind of a followup here just so I'm
clear is what you're saying
is if there's no game of chance license
whatever you called it the game operator
employer then you cannot have historical
horse racing
correct so really the only local
option in your opinion that would need
to be in here would be game of the games
of chance is that correct if we were to
do that well if you were to do it that
would work unless a community didn't
mind having craps and T and blackjack in
their Community but didn't want an
electronic game so I understand where
representative rord was going and saying
we want to do one or the other but you
know that's that's what I'm saying the
nitty-gritty of how you get there I
think think needs more time understood
now thank you um second
question you mentioned the mor current
moratorium when does that expire the
current moratorium expires July 1 of
this year and there are now at least
three bills one uh is up in the senate
in fact tomorrow that would extend that
to seven years um and have the same
language that you folks have passed in
the house allowing these five applicants
well
okay I think I have one more for you
hold
on so you said that you're not opposed
to local option but you don't believe
this bill or Amendment does
that in very simple terms how what would
this have to do or say so you would say
okay I'm good with the local option well
for instance the very first line under
28 on line 12 line 13 for facilities
permitted after July 1
2024 honestly I don't know what that
means but I think it I think what it
means to say is for a
new uh games of chance facility okay
that was not otherwise in the pipeline
are not otherwise operating but I'm not
sure it really clearly states that
because for instance even our current
facilities would have to get relicensed
they C you currently you change the law
to make it every three years so in
2026 for instance everyone who got
licensed last year is going to have to
get licensed again would they then come
under this section that would be a
concern of ours because the way that
it's drafted I think we can get to where
they where the sponsor wants to be but
I'm not sure that that particular
sentence is the correct one so is that
you the ability to repeal is an issue
and the language that allows a community
to repeal I mean again some of these
facilities you June 8th 2021 was the
effective date of historic horse racing
for instance okay we're now in
2024 we're almost three years out and
Conway and um
Rochester who are
original qualifiers are yet to be
operating this would allow a town to
repeal if a facility didn't operate
within 3 years it's taken those those
two facilities that long to get up and
running and I don't think either of them
anticipate being up and running before
June 8 so they go past the three-year
window so in other words you know I
think that that would need to be
addressed that if somebody was in the
process of putting a facility in place
they couldn't have a a revote that would
take away because you've invested a
great deal of money to get to even
before you open the
doors okay further questions
CA and thank you for
your uh next we'll call Curtis
Meer can we have her go
first we're more than happy to have I've
only got two more if Deborah would like
to go first that's fine Deborah Warner
thank
you I very much appreciate this
opportunity thank you Mr chairman and
members of this committee um Dr Deborah
Warner from Littleton and uh we are
folks who were very surprised one day
when we had a visit from uh someone who
wanted to introduce a Cano casino to our
community and there was a listening
session up at the high school in our
town of 6000 more than 100 people came
which for us is a lot and um many many
people spoke and 95% of the people who
got up uh had negative things to say and
then there were a few that the other 5%
said positive things that they would
like a casino in town and uh there was
quite a bit of um concern of this and we
were told by the town um officials that
there was nothing at all we could do
about it just listen and see and so um
we were pretty disheartened by all of
that because of our experiences and such
and many people had um negative
experiences in their family am and
upbringing and socially to uh consider
the casino as a positive addition to our
really wonderful community that we're
very proud of uh Littleton has 6,000
people it has 42 restaurants it has
20,000 people a day who come uh to our
industry and shopping uh it's a
happening place and we're quite pleased
with it there's a lot of volunteer work
and a lot of community um camaraderie
people know each other they care about
each other and we take care of each
other and so I want to bring forward our
concerns on your handout I sent you a
passed it around for you all as my name
at the top Warner um we ask you to vote
to adopt this amendment I understand um
there are some issues that perhaps a
little wording change could be involved
um but that you would adopt it and then
put O A to pass as amended uh for the
underlying bill um just New Hampshire
does things right we try to do new
things and we try to do good things and
we try to do them right I have been
attending the commission to study the
chable gambling and in fact I made a
presentation to them last month about
local option um they're discussing it
see what can be done but as you know for
Littleton we have a consideration that's
right in the wings uh the people
involved have told me that they're still
in the hopper and they even though the
the director has not named them uh they
themselves have told us uh that they are
in the works in the pipeline um I
believe that the reason for a moratorium
is so that the rules the laws can catch
up with gaps that were not fully
considered or could not be considered at
the first uh round of the new laws and
so um I think we need to comprehend the
impact of this law the law the rsas are
in several places the games of chance
and the historic horse rating are in
completely separate rsas uh makes it a
little difficult to follow and um it was
quite a thing touring around that spot
but I think we need to consider it those
laws all regulate the honest operation
of Casino
and what the state and would do with the
money and where the money goes but
there's no consideration really in that
law of the source of that money all of
the money of the $170 million that in
2023 came in uh to the casinos uh to use
and distribute in the ways that are
according to the law all of that $170
million came out of people's pockets in
those locations now they freely gave it
it's their risk that they took um but
there are many many consequences and
there are many uh things affected by the
gambling industry and it's highly
associated with addiction being within
10 miles of a casino doubles your risk
of being a gambling addict that's you
know like having any other toxic
substance that's nearby it gets
regulated and it's a good thing that it
would be
that's not a bigotry you know that's not
a it's not a a um a bias against it it's
just happens to be facts there are other
um reasons why local people might not
want to have a casino in their territory
uh but we we need to look at responsible
sourcing of the gambling money where's
it coming from it's in a community right
now the little communities that house
the casinos and case it would be a
little community and Salem OR Nasha
would be a big Community uh but that
$170 million is coming out of somewhere
and it's not going into the local
economy
um let's see I'm you can read through my
testimony and and see the various
smaller points that are important with
this but in terms of how this goes and
what is the state's responsibility to
something that is significantly
impacting a community and that the
community has no chance to say yes or no
I think that's the major question for
this committee and I think it's really
important if you look at page two you
see a graph it is a um a ratio of the
revenues over the first four the last
four years from 20 through 23 of how
much income was uh produced at the
casinos it has gone up quite
significantly in that period of time and
this is a ratio of that to the personal
consumption expenditures that's from the
um bea.gov uh numbers it's like a gross
national product but it's at the the
state level and it's about expenditures
specifically and so if you made this
ratio you can see that it's changing
over time very quickly and if you were
to look at what will it be in five or 10
years it's likely to go up that's wanted
to increase the number of places that
there are casinos and they're building
and so of course numbers like that will
be going up and so you look at well if
that money is no longer in the local
community what happens to the local
economy and what happens to the
businesses um it is known that it can
affect the restaurant industry um
because casinos are often
self-sufficient and have um cheaper food
and delicious food and such and people
are attracted to that venue for good
reasons for that but does have an impact
on the local
businesses
um there are negative and positive
reasons why people might vote about
casinos in terms of the positive and um
they might have taxes that they could
collect and attractions to the venue and
a profitable owner investment selective
charitable support there is a big
waiting list for Charities to get in on
this money by the way it's a lot of
money and it's very nice for the
Charities who get it by the way there
are negative issues that I just
mentioned a few minutes
ago there is a deep precedence in laws
and Zoning that protects the general
welfare of the
community and that is why alcohol is
regulated that's why drugs are regulated
and things like that and and there there
is reason to know that there can be some
very significant health effects and
economic and social effects with uh
gambling and here especially with
casinos there's a lot of research on
their impact so in terms of why would
the government get involved is that why
would a state level decision affect a
local community is if you were going to
do
um public domain and take over a place
and say it's for the public good we need
this
energy plant and it's going to have to
be here and the local preferences often
would get overridden in that case
however in terms of something that is
not for the public good it's it's for
the the profit of the investors it's for
the state taxes and it's for select
Charities um that doesn't meet that
threshold in terms of our decision
making and so I think is excellent
reason for us to put this decision in
the local hands it is the people in the
community who know the local assets
their potentials the treasures their
society you know whatever it is that
they treasure in their community that
they could make that decision and
there's a balance between those
positives and negatives and each of us
in this room May certainly have a
different opinion of where we would vote
locally on such a thing and that's part
of the real strength of our system that
we're able to have dis disagreements
we're able to have different opinions
and that we look at in the end what does
the community decide I think that's a
really important part of appreciating
the value of local option
so responsible sourcing of gambling
money is how I'm framing this is because
the money does come from somewhere and
we need to be barely considerate of
where it's coming from and it's coming
from the communities it affects the
communities and so
um we've did copy as you heard the Kino
statute and as representative rokford
explained uh we made sure that the exit
plan if used or and voted on that it's
considerate of the Investments made by
the the casino company compes themselves
and so if those numbers need a little
tweaking I don't have a problem with
that on the last page of my handout is
our story you can read it and have a cup
of cocoa and help us out it would be
very nice we do have um an urgency for
this I I do believe that it's not in the
law that the people in the pipeline uh
are automatically grandfathered in I
would certainly like it to be that they
are um subject to the new law because it
g that's a point of a moratorium is that
you try to catch up um with the holes
and the gaps that were in the problem in
the first place there were some
questions in terms of
um
the I don't believe it's written so that
they the facilities in place would need
to apply for a license all over again I
think we we were trying to grandfather
them in in the way that we wrote that um
but that might need a little bit of
tweaking for the HHR or some of those
that are
um you know that got an immediate
granting of their license at the state
level but didn't build yet and it's
almost coming up on three years U that's
quite understandable if they were
already in this before we even thought
this of this law that makes sense it
does sound also in the way that um the
gentleman who's the lobbyist um brought
up that point is that uh it could be
that the Strategic entry to this local
option um consideration might be through
the games gaming parlor itself the goe
um that it that might be the section
that needs to be emphasized and that if
the HHR is 100% dependent upon the
gaming um operator license and facility
that that might be all right to
eliminate that so that there's not
confusion about which one you are voting
in or voting out so if those time frames
need to change I don't have a problem
with that and if we want to consider the
impact of taking HHR out of the mix
because it's 100% dependent upon that
and take your word for that I mean that
that really does make sense to me
because it would be more strategic it
was a very complicated uh thing with
these several
statutes there were perhaps some other
things uh this thing about seven days
that she brought up um I that was just
from the King know and I think that this
committee might want to change that but
I think that this very much is germine
to this committee I think that you are
the ones who really have the best
interests of the communities in the
center of your vision and your mission
here and so I think it is in the right
place I'm very very glad that this is
coming to your attention I don't think
handling this means that in the future
all gambling legislation is going to
head your way please don't think that
you're opening the gate to a flood of
gambling bills but I think that this
aspect of it is very very local so thank
questions seeing no questions um I will
let the final speaker speak and then I'm
just going to make a couple
Meer
hello I'm the Reverend Curtis Meer I'm
from Littleton I really came here to
back up Deb but first things is um I
wish I could bring you greetings from my
mother the representative Katie Meer who
was chair of this Committee in 1998
she's in heaven now but she would want
me to say hello and uh wish courage and
fortitude to you all in your work um so
basically uh I just wanted to say that
uh I'm not against gambling per se I
maybe I'm maybe you expected that with
this thing around my neck but I I I am
sure that I bought the winning lottery
ticket yesterday so I'm not against
gambling but uh the point of all this
and our concern up in Littleton is
really about a fixed facility and what
that would bring in terms of um human
traffic and car traffic and um potential
ills in the in the community and we were
just very very concerned about that and
and knowing about Kino and how there was
local option in Kino we thought there
would be consistency on principle that
when it comes to gaming because gaming
is so fraught uh in debate and and in
the public that if Kino little machines
in various places was important enough
to have local option then why not a
whole facility it would seem in Congress
or odd to constituents I think to say
well they trust us to make the decision
about little machines and places but we
can't have a say about a whole facility
that would impact our community and how
it might impact our community so um so I
would encourage um a vote for this
amendment thank you thank you further
comments or
questions seeing none I'm not going to
quite close the hearing yet um what I
would highly recommend is um you all get
together with representative rord who is
the sponsor um maybe even get in contact
with Mr Newman here who says he can see
away with some changes you you've heard
about all the potential downfalls on
this I think if it has um the ability to
go through it's going to take some
changes um so maybe you all can work
together get uh representative roord
involved with that
um we are getting close to the end of
our house session or
our before our crossover bills we've got
very limited time remaining so I would
highly recommend if you intend to make
some changes or representative rfor
wants to make some changes that it's
done very rapidly so I will leave it at
that Mr Newman's there you can uh talk
with him about it we as a committee I do
not believe are going to get involved
with major major rewrites of this that's
not going to be uh our responsibility so
just so everybody's under on the same
page does that make sense
questions seeing none we'll close the
hearing on HB
tomorrow
call Mr
chairman Mr chairman representative
lales next week we we meet on Monday
correct I just sent in that yes the
remaining exec bills are all scheduled
for Monday um but that's leaving us the
following Wednesday for anything that
might get pushed out as an example maybe
you